Ah, jetzt. Hä?
Alter, warum? Kann mir mal
irgendjemand erklären, warum ist Windows
so scheiße?
Und
es ändert sich jedes Mal irgendwas,
ohne dass man was umstellt.
Ihr könnt mir nicht erzählen, dass es an OBS liegt.
Das liegt 100% an Windows,
was irgendwas an Device IDs oder so
ändert, random.
Und dann findet OBS das Mikrofon
nicht mehr. Was ist das? Ich hab
legit nix. Ich weiß, das sagt jeder, ja?
Egal, wo du...
Wenn irgendwo einer was kaputt gemacht hat,
sagt er immer, ich hab gar nix gemacht.
Aber ich war nicht... Ich könnte es
sogar beweisen. Ich war seit einer
Woche nicht mehr auf diesen Windows-Grund eingeloggt.
Wie soll ich was umgestellt haben?
Ne, aber ich glaube,
mittlerweile
ist es eher so, dass Microsoft uns
beweisen müsste, dass es nicht an ihnen liegt.
Was ich für ein Mikrofon habe jetzt,
das ist das Mikrofon von meinem
MMX300-Headset.
Das ist an einem Audio-Interface
dran.
An so einem USB-Audio-Interface.
Also nix, nix Tolles.
Für Videoaufnahmen habe ich immer noch
einen Plu-Yeti tatsächlich schon seit Jahren.
Das ist auch ganz okay. Das tut es.
Das schließt man per USB an und dann...
Dann geht's halt, ne?
So, wir müssen mal ein bisschen was
Entspannteres machen. Was haben wir hier?
Chilled Summer Tunes.
Das ist mir fast schon zu gechillt, das Summer Tunes.
Ja.
Was war das eigentlich? War es irgendjemand,
der das schon gepostet hat hier eben?
Microsoft to kill Windows Control Panel
in favor of Settings App.
Naja, es war ja, es war ja nur
eine Frage der Zeit, bis das hier rausfliegt.
Das Ding ist,
ich frage mich,
was macht man mit den
Settings, wo
man nur hier drüber hinkommt?
Gibt es das
überhaupt noch?
Zum Beispiel, Control Panel,
Sound,
das da.
Nee, du, dankeschön für den Sub.
Und GoWizard, POG
Subscriptions, Leute. Massive Subs.
Kommt man da
überhaupt hin?
Über die System
Settings. Das
probieren wir doch jetzt mal.
Settings.
Okay. Also.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal
genauso einfach wie über das Control Panel.
Sound.
Sound
Settings. Ja, da komme ich in
dieses Kack-Menü. Wolle, dankeschön
für den Sub. Da komme ich in dieses Kack-Menü.
In dieses Kack-Menü will ich nicht.
Weil ich da manche Sachen nicht umstellen kann.
Ja, was ich da zum Beispiel nicht umstellen kann, ist
das hier.
Also sprich, mit welcher
Sample Rate das Ganze läuft. Und mein Audio
Interface, zumindest sagt der Hersteller
das, die empfehlen über
optischen Anschluss 48 Kilohertz
anstatt 44,1. Warum auch
immer, keine Ahnung. Normaler ist 44,1,
aber, ja.
Oder kommt man
da irgendwie hin?
Output Devices?
Input Devices?
More Sound Settings vielleicht?
Aha!
Okay.
Immerhin, man kommt hin.
Aber es gibt garantiert
Sachen, zum Beispiel
Wie sieht das mit Printer Settings
aus, zum Beispiel?
View Devices and Printers. Na gut, da habe ich
hier keine. Ach, das geht jetzt schon
das hier noch auf. Advanced
Printers. Ah, ne, hier ist doch mein Drucker.
Ups.
Ja, also, solange
die sichergestellt haben, und das ist halt das, wo ich
mir bei Microsoft immer nicht sicher bin, das wirkt
immer nicht so wie von
langer Hand
geplant und durchdacht.
Solange die sichergestellt haben,
dass du alle notwendigen Settings Menüs
auch über das alte Settings
erreichen, äh, über das neue, Schwachsinn.
Also, wo du das nicht mehr, das wollte ich sagen,
dass du nicht mehr das alte Settings brauchst,
dann
ist es okay.
Warte mal hier.
Ne, ne, in die alten Settings. Gehen wir mal davon aus,
ich will irgendwelche speziellen IP Settings
einstellen. Ja, also
ich möchte zum Beispiel, äh, Jumbo Frames
einschalten oder so.
Das macht ja normalerweise kaum einer unter Windows,
aber gehen wir mal davon aus.
Wie komme ich in das spezielle Netzwerkmenü?
Das ist in der Tat eine gute Frage.
Wie komme ich da hin? So, über
Control Panels.
Network. Ja.
Adapter Settings. Hier.
Da würde ich da
hinkommen.
Adapter Settings.
Managed Network Adapter
Settings. Okay, vielleicht hier drüber.
Ne.
20 Tabs offenen Chrome. Wie jetzt?
Das ist noch nix. Du hast
noch gar nicht alles gesehen. Hier haben wir noch, da haben wir
noch. Du hast
den vollen Chrome. Meine 4M habe ich auch nicht.
Ja, wie kommt man da rein?
Das ist Hardware Connection Properties
vielleicht. Ne.
Okay, das ist in der Tat
blöd, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Wie kommt man
in dieses Menü? Also, weil zum Beispiel
gehen wir mal davon aus, ich will
jetzt, achso, ja, okay, ich muss
jetzt Admin Zeug eingeben, alles klar.
Mal angenommen, ich will jetzt in die
IPv4 Settings und dort
irgendwelche
Advanced, wo kann man denn,
äh, wo kann man denn hier unter
Windows überhaupt, wenn man möchte,
Jumbo Frames konfigurieren?
Kann man das überhaupt?
Hier vielleicht? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ich, ich, ich
wishe nicht zu proceeden.
Gut, wie dem auch sei, hier kannst du bestimmt
Sachen machen, die du hier nicht machen kannst.
Ja.
Das kenne ich. Das habe ich,
das habe ich gesehen auf Reddit.
Das habe ich, haltet euch mal fest,
das habe ich auf Reddit gesehen, bevor ich das jetzt aufmache.
Ich bin, also ich bin mir nicht sicher
gewesen, ob das stimmt, was ich auf
Reddit gepostet habe, aber nachdem das jetzt ein offizieller
Link sogar ist, auf irgendein
Bundesblablub ist es
wahrscheinlich echt. Und zwar, da ging es um Game,
Gamesförderung. Ja.
Passt mal auf. Welche
herausragenden,
bahnbrechenden Spiele, äh,
mit unter anderem euren Steuergeldern
auch gefördert wird? Guckt euch das mal an.
Massive.
Geil, oder?
Ratet mal. Ratet mal. Nicht
nachgucken, Leute. Guckt nicht nach.
Was meint ihr, wie viel Fördergelder man da hierfür
bekommt?
Was meint ihr, wie viel, wie viel
Fördergelder kriegt man für Modern Snake?
In Deutschland.
Ratet mal. Nicht nachgucken.
Haben wir überhaupt noch Entwickler
Studios? Ne, haben wir nicht. Wir haben halt noch sowas
hier.
100.000? Ne.
Ich überleg grad, was haben wir denn? Was haben wir denn in Deutschland
denn noch für Entwickler?
Crytek.
Sind die noch in Deutschland überhaupt?
Crytek ist das erste, was mir
einfällt. Gibt es
Blue Byte überhaupt noch?
Ubisoft gibt es ein paar Mal
in Deutschland, das weiß ich, aber das zählt für mich
nicht als eigenes.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Mir fällt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel ein.
Piranha Bytes.
Die gibt es auch nicht mehr, oder?
Die Gothic, Leute.
Zumindest, so, jetzt revealen wir
das hier erstmal. Man bekommt für so ein
geiles Game
176.000 Euro Förderung.
Für 176.000 Euro
kann man auch was sinnvolles machen.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel könnte ich
hier im Ort den einen Parkplatz
neu bauen, den du gar nicht mal, wo du
gar nicht mal drauf fahren kannst, weil er so viele Löcher hat.
176.000 Euro
Forderung gibt es. Laufzeit, guckt euch das
mal an. Die haben eineinhalb Jahre
an Modern Snake entwickelt.
Wo gibt es denn das Game
überhaupt?
Okay, Leute, hier.
Bam.
Wir haben sogar noch
deutsche Entwicklerstudios,
die so geile Sachen auf die Reihe kriegen.
Was? Das Handy spielt
mit der Schlange. Der Pixel,
die Pixel frisst und dabei immer länger und schwerer
zur Steuer mit. Eines der bekanntesten Videospiele
aller Zeiten. Moment, und warum
genau braucht es jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise Förderung?
Max, lass uns
in Steam ein Spiel, ganz ehrlich,
ich bin der Meinung,
Spiele, die deutsche Spielförderung
brauchen, die sind es wahrscheinlich eh nicht wert.
Weil, die
übernehmen, glaube ich, auch nur maximal die Hälfte
der Kosten. Dann fragt man sich, wie kann dieses Spiel
überhaupt 300.000 Euro gekostet haben?
Das sieht aus wie so ein Nachmittags-
Projekt von
Ich lerne Unity oder so.
Okay, wir suchen mal danach.
Modern Snake.
Ja, Modern Snake, da sind wir.
Massive.
Die Skizze entstand vor Projektbeginn
als frühes, na geil.
Das Spiel
hat außer einer Skizze nichts zu zeigen
oder was? Bei einer Förderungs-
Moment,
die haben die Seite nur
erstellt, dass sie Fördergelder
kriegen oder wie? Wollen die mich
verarschen oder was?
Spot über Modern Snake. Ja.
Ist ja auch so. Kann man
ja auch spotten. Ja, natürlich.
Übel, easy.
Leute, das sieht doch jetzt mal ernsthaft, das sieht
wirklich aus wie ein Unity-Projekt, was einer
nachmittags so zum Üben ein bisschen bastelt.
Parallel zu dem Spiel gibt es politisch
eine Spielerfahrung, bevor wir jetzt absolut teure
anmutende Projekte... Okay, mal gucken.
Vielleicht flamen wir es ja auch zu Unrecht.
Gut, die erzählen auf der Gamescom, da ist
Robert Habeck nicht allein. Auf der Gamescom haben
sich schon viele hingestellt und ultra viel Bullshit gelabert.
Man könnte sogar so weit
gehen, dass überall hingestellt wird
und viel Bullshit gelabert wird.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Soll ich euch mal meine Meinung sagen
zu der ganzen Förderungsgeschichte? Ich habe prinzipiell
nichts gegen Förderung, aber es wäre
durchaus sinnvoll, überhaupt so
den Standort an sich attraktiv zu machen
und nicht die Leute mit Bürokratie
voll zu scheißen,
sodass hier keiner mehr irgendwelche Unternehmen
gründen will oder neue Projekte starten will.
Anstatt jetzt gefühlt, anstatt jetzt
gezielt irgendwelche eigenen Sachen zu fördern.
Vielleicht sollte man sich insgesamt überlegen,
ob das vielleicht einen Grund hat, warum
die Leute keinen Bock haben, hier sowas zu entwickeln.
Okay, nicht unbedingt Modern Snake, aber
allgemein Games.
Beziehungsweise es ist ja nicht nur Games.
Es rennen ja reihenweise auch die Leute
weg. Also wir haben es hier
teilweise bürokratisch so extrem
übertrieben.
Ja, das Gründen, das Gründen
ist ja auch eines der kleineren
Probleme. Ich meine, ich habe
auch eine Firma gegründet vor ein paar Jahren.
So, und ich mache damit legit
nichts. Das heißt, ich muss fast nichts machen,
aber trotzdem muss ich mich hin und wieder
mit bürokratischen Sachen auseinandersetzen.
So, und als wenn ich mir überlege, wie das
erst ist, wenn du was machst,
da hast du keinen Bock mehr.
Der Lindner, der muss jetzt natürlich seinen
Standardspruch sagen, der Markt regelt das.
Letztens habe ich auf Reddit,
äh, nicht auf Reddit, auf Twitter
wieder die üblichen Spezialisten gesehen.
Da hat einer auf, man kann, man kann
ja leider auf Twitter, also sorry, auf
x ehemals Twitter, man kann keine
Nachrichten mehr verlinken, gescheit und posten, deswegen
kann ich euch das jetzt nicht zeigen. Sinngemäß
hat sich dort einer
über den Lindner lustig gemacht. Eine Sache,
die ich auch nicht, da kann ich
mich mit anfreunden. Kannst du
dich viel drüber lustig machen, aber zumindest hat
einer ein Bild gepostet von einer Pommes Frites,
eine Tüte Pommes Frites auf der Gamescom.
Und hat dann irgendwie
gepostet, irgendwie 6,50 Euro
und es waren am Ende irgendwie 12, 12 Pommes Frites
mit einem Klecks Mayonnaise drauf.
So, und
da haben sie sich dann drüber lustig
gemacht auf Twitter und haben so gesagt,
ähm
ist das alles so teuer ist
und sonst was. Und irgendwann kam dann einer an und
meinte, ja, so wie
unser Finanzminister jetzt irgendwie sagen würde,
der freie Markt regelt das.
Und wenn er es nicht regelt, dann ist er nicht
frei genug. Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
wie bescheuert kann man sein, dieses Beispiel,
man kann sich beim Lindner über vieles lustig
machen, aber wie bescheuert kann man sein,
dieses Beispiel bei einer Pommes Frites von der
Gamescom zu posten.
Pommes Frites von der Gamescom haben so
nichts mit freiem Markt zu tun.
Oder wie, was meint ihr,
wie viele, wie viele freie, offen,
wie, wie, wie offen ist da, wie,
wie kannst du auf die Gamescom gehen und einfach mal
da deinen Pommes Frites Stand hinstellen?
Also da hat sich quasi
selbst jebaitet der Typ.
Mit dem Post.
Das ist stimmt, was er sich eigentlich
drüber lustig machen wollte.
Aber x ehemals, äh,
doch, x ehemals Twitter hast eh so viele Spezialisten
am Start, ja.
Ja. Das ist übrigens nicht der Grund, warum wir nicht mehr
auf die Gamescom gehen. Der Grund, warum ich nicht mehr auf die Gamescom
gehe, ist, weil es eigentlich überhaupt nichts bringt,
auf die Gamescom zu gehen. Du befährst auf der Gamescom
nahezu nichts spannendes Neues.
Wo man das nicht sagen, nicht pauschal
sagen kann, kaum, kaum,
was äh, spannendes Neues.
So, so
eins, zwei Sachen gibt's dann vielleicht schon, aber die hättste
daheim auf irgendeinem, wenn's dich
interessiert, in irgendeiner Pressekonferenz
irgendeine Twitch-Übertragung auch mitgekriegt.
Ansonsten kannst du die Gamescom
ist einfach nur anstrengend
und voll
und
für viele als Community-Event
vielleicht ganz cool, ja, dass man mal wieder
Leute sieht, die man lange nicht gesehen hat
oder Leute, die man sonst nur online sieht und sowas. Dafür ist das
gut, aber für den eigentlichen
Sinn hinter der Gamescom kannst du's vergessen.
Ja. Ja, Gamesförderung,
ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich,
hm, da hab ich keine Hoffnung, dass da was
Gescheites aus Deutschland in nächster Zeit noch kommt.
Meiner Meinung nach liegt das generell,
dass der Standort da nicht attraktiv genug
für ist. Du hast hier so krasse
bürokratische Auflagen,
so, wir machen mal kurz OS-Updates.
Wollen wir grad dabei, lass doch mal gucken.
Deutsche Entwickler
Entwickler-Studios
Gucken wir doch mal.
Die größten Entwickler 2023, okay.
Made in Germany, ja, da ist dann
sowas wie Gothic und so dabei, was halt
so, oder Anno oder Siedler oder so,
was es, glaub ich, alles so gar nicht mehr gibt.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist
eine History quasi.
Okay, Games, was es noch immer für Seiten gibt.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Ubisoft, ja, das wusste ich, dass es die ein paar Mal
in Deutschland gibt. Hier, hier haben wir noch mehr
Ubisoft, da. Da, nochmal.
Das wusste ich eigentlich, aber das zählt für mich.
Crytek, Crytek zählt für mich.
Crytek ist auch, Inno, stimmt!
Die gibt es tatsächlich auch noch.
Die gibt, an die hätte ich
jetzt gar nicht gedacht, ja.
Die gibt es irgendwie
kaputt. Das Ding ist
halt, mir fällt
spontan halt einfach
nichts ein von Inno Games
aus dem Kopf. Okay,
wenn ich mir das so angucke, ne,
dann weißt du schon Bescheid, Alter.
Gibt es die Leute von, sind das nicht
die hier?
Sind das nicht die? Die scheinen es noch
zu geben. Ah, okay.
Aber wie gesagt, Crytek ist der einzige,
der mir, Jäger gibt es auch noch,
ja.
Aber der Rest,
der ehemals Bekannten,
ist allerdings alles, alles
deadge. Ja, aber
wie gesagt, Far Cry, äh, nicht Far Cry,
Crytek ist auch das einzige, was mir seit Jahren
spontan einfällt und was es immer noch gibt.
Ja, da war ich sogar schon.
Frankfurt.
Also nicht drin. Äh, ja, das habe ich
auch gesehen. Ja, so, das ist, das ist auch so ne,
so ne moderne Marketinggeschichte,
die ist, die, das Spiel ist so inoffiziell,
dass es Leute schon auf Twitch streamen.
So inoffiziell ist das.
Ich hab gestern, ich hab gestern
tatsächlich ein bisschen streamen geguckt.
Ich muss sagen, mich hat's
jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht so
angesprochen. Aber mal gucken.
Insgesamt muss
man ja sagen,
hat Valve ja nen relativ guten
Output zu
ist gutes Spiel Ratio.
Lassen wir dieses
Dota-Kartenspiel mal weg.
Weiß gar, ich weiß gar nicht,
Artifact hieß das, oder?
Wie ist dieses Dota-Kartenspiel,
was dann wieder eingestellt wurde?
Ja, es gibt kein Half-Life 3, Left 4 Dead 3,
Portal 3, 3er machen die ja nicht.
Artifact, ja.
Das ist aber auch das einzige Valve-Spiel,
was mir so einfällt, was so
komplett schlecht
angekommen ist und in der Versenkung
verschwunden ist. Alle anderen Games
waren
semi-erfolgreich bis sehr erfolgreich.
Also die haben immer noch
ein ziemlich gutes Verhältnis aus
Releases zu
ist ziemlich gut.
Wobei man aber bei Valve sagen muss,
die können sich das auch leisten,
alle Lichtjahre mal so nen Game rauszubringen,
weil die haben halt Steam und verdienen sich
dumm und dämlich.
Die müssen halt keine Games machen, um zu überleben.
Die können halt ab und zu
mal Games machen, wenn sie Bock drauf haben
und dann auch Jahre
an Games rumwerkeln
und die wieder einstampfen, wenn nichts
Gescheites dabei rauskommt.
Payload not recognized, okay, alles klar.
Was auch immer.
Oh, ich brauche meine Uhr ausziehen.
Fällt mir eigentlich irgendwie seit gestern
Mittag oder so an.
Eine Garmin-Uhr.
Sleep-Tracked, Leute.
Ich hatte heute bloß 81% Sleep-Score.
Gestern hatte ich
90% Sleep-Score. Ich merke keinen Unterschied.
Aber wenn Garmin
das sagt...
Max, was hast du die Woche gemacht?
Tja, nicht viel.
Einmal nach Frankfurt gefahren auf die Arbeit.
Ansonsten
Homeoffice gearbeitet.
Meine tägliche Runde gerannt.
Und ansonsten hauptsächlich rumgegammelt.
Die restliche Zeit.
Wirklich viel
Ich habe ein paar Sachen auf Steam gespielt.
Aber nichts spannendes.
Irgendwelche uralten Boomer-Shooters.
Es gibt nichts spannendes zu erzählen.
Arsch, by the way.
Gucken, ob es hier
neue Updates gibt.
Wow, alles wurde geupdatet.
Guck mal hier.
Ryder,
Pycharm, Goland, Rustyrd.
Passt mal auf,
die CPU-Auslastung
eskaliert gleich, sobald es anfängt
das Zeug zu entpacken. Guck mal hier.
Einfach mal Updates installieren
und 8 CPU-Kerne auslasten.
Easy.
Ihr könnt mir ja erzählen, was ihr Spannendes die Woche gemacht habt.
Vielleicht ist da irgendwas interessantes dabei.
Irgendwas spannenderes dabei als bei mir.
Ich war gestern.
Max, es gibt Updates.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich zusammen.
Ich war seit über einem Monat gestern zum ersten Mal
wieder Fahrrad fahren.
Das hat sich einfach nicht so richtig ergeben.
Entweder war das Wetter kacke für Fahrrad fahren
oder ich hatte an dem Tag keine Zeit.
Ich war jetzt fast einen Monat nicht Fahrrad fahren.
Ich war gestern zum ersten Mal wieder zwei Stunden
eine Runde Fahrrad fahren.
Und Leute,
Alter, erstens tut mir der Arsch weh.
Das ist aber immer so.
Wenn man nach einer Weile wieder auf dem Sattel sitzt.
Und
meine Garmin,
mein Fahrrad-Computer
meint minus 5 Performance.
Also ich sacke jetzt.
Richtig.
Ja, aber so einen Monat nicht auf dem Fahrrad gesessen, merkt man halt.
Stimmt.
Ja, dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Da habe ich ja letztens dazu aufgerufen,
wer ein bisschen Kohle locker hat
und möchte, dass Semi wieder
laufen kann.
Der kann was spenden
für Semi. Und anscheinend ist es
jetzt so, dass
das Geld zusammengekommen ist.
Circa 2.000 Euro.
Also nice an alle, die mitgespendet
haben. Sei es jetzt über PayPal
oder Überweisung oder später
haben die auch noch eine GoFundMe-Seite gemacht.
Die Kohle ist zusammengekommen
und Semi wurde, das habe ich auch schon,
das habe ich auch schon gelesen,
Semi wurde operiert. Also, nur mal für alle, die es nicht
mitgekriegt haben, das ist ein Tierheim hier bei mir in der Nähe.
Das ist in irgendwie
30 Minuten im Auto weg. Ich habe vergessen, wie da ordnet.
Irgendwas mit B
oder mit G.
Moment.
Über uns Kontakt.
Die sind in
Egal. Impressum.
Jede Seite in Deutschland braucht ein Impressum.
Alle Anzeige ist raus.
Bibergemünd. Ja, genau.
Und die haben einen Spendenaufruf
gestartet. Die haben eine Katze abgegeben
bekommen mit zwei gebrochenen Beinen.
Vermutlich wurde die angefahren von einem Auto oder sowas.
Details weiß man nicht.
Und der hat dringende
Operationen gebraucht, dass er
wieder laufen kann. Umso länger das Ganze geht,
umso schlechter wird das natürlich.
Und die hatten einen Spendenaufruf
auch hier in der Zeitung. Ich habe das hier auch noch mal
im Stream gezeigt.
Die Kohle ist zusammengekommen.
Sammy konnte operiert werden.
Also gab es hier das erste Update.
Sie sind super happy,
dass die Leute
was gespendet haben. Also
nice Leute. Dankeschön, wer mitgemacht
hat.
Wer dazu beigetragen hat.
Morgen steht die wichtige Operation
für Sammy an. Bitte drückt alle fest die Daumen.
Morgen war letzte Woche Mittwoch.
Das ist also schon passiert.
Sechs bis acht Wochen muss er in der
Box sitzen. Dann geht es ihm hoffentlich wieder
gut. Und jetzt
gibt es gute Nachrichten. Sammy ist
wach und die Operation war erfolgreich.
Guck, Sammys Bein ist vernagelt
und wieder gerade. Sammy
selbst hat noch so ein Ding um den Hals, dass er
nicht dran rumnagen und nicht dran rumlecken kann.
Und sie schreiben
hier, der Bruch konnte korrigiert werden.
Es war eine lange Operation und der Eingriff war
sehr kompliziert.
Anders als gedacht ist der Bruch schätzungsweise
zwei Wochen alt. Also sprich, das ist schon eine
Weile her, wo der angefangen wurde. Also ich sage jetzt mal
angefangen. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Vermute ich jetzt.
Einfach mal. Aufgrund der Verzögerung
haben sich Umliegende sein und leider bereits
zurückgebildet. In den kommenden Wochen muss Sammy
strikte Boxruhe einhalten.
Zu einer späteren Zeit
probiert er zusätzlich Physiotherapie an, um die Muskulatur
wieder aufzuhalten. Es gibt sogar Physiotherapie
für Katzen mittlerweile.
Der zweite Bruch am linken Mittelfuß konnte
ohne chirurgischen Eingriff behandelt werden.
Durch die Ruhe wird dieser von selbst
heilen. Also quasi
das da vermutlich.
Weil ich Röntgenbilder von Katzen
interpretieren kann.
Wir sind unendlich erleichtert,
dass die Operation erfolgreich verlaufen ist
und Sammy sich sicher aus der
Narkose erwacht ist. Ein herzliches Dankeschön an
ein großartiges Team der Wettpraxis
für Kleintiere. Da ist Sammy.
Sammy weiß es noch nicht
und Sammy wird es wahrscheinlich
auch nie
verstehen, aber ich hoffe Sammy
ist happy und kann wieder laufen
nach der
Operation. Also Leute,
wer gespendet hat, habt ihr mal was Gutes getan.
Besser als das Geld an
Jesus oder sonst wen zu überweisen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
richtig angekommen.
Dann hoffen wir mal,
dass das alles gut läuft
und Sammy auch
gut läuft
in 6, 7, 8 Wochen.
Ich schreib
dir nochmal eine E-Mail
in ein paar Wochen,
wie es aussieht.
Und wenn ihr wollt, theoretisch
es ist ja nicht weit von mir weg,
theoretisch könnte ich sogar
vorbeifahren und mal ein Video von Sammy
aufnehmen.
Mach ich auch so,
ich habe noch nie gespendet
an irgendeine große Organisation.
Ne, das sind nicht meine.
Das ist die, wo ich letztens im Stream
gezeigt habe, dass die sich die
Beine gebrochen hat und Spenden braucht.
Und es haben anscheinend auch genug Leute
mitgemacht, weil die 2.000 Euro sind zusammengekommen.
Ich habe auch noch nie an große
Organisationen gespendet.
Ich habe bisher auch immer nur, und das werde ich auch mal
weiterhin so machen, an lokale Tierheime
und sowas gespendet.
Schon an mehrere.
Ich habe an das Tierheim in Gelnhausen schon was
gespendet, hier an die Katzen, links an die hier.
Ich habe noch nie für arme Kinder
in Afrika gespendet, aber letztendlich kann
auch jeder mit seiner Kohle machen, was er will.
Wichtig ist nur,
dass es euch persönlich
halt irgendwie anspricht.
Wenn euch das irgendwie ein gutes Gefühl gibt
oder wenn ihr denkt, ey, das ist was, was mir persönlich wichtig
ist,
das ist das Wichtigste.
Ob das irgendjemand anderes für wichtig hält,
ob ich das für wichtig halte, ist vollkommen egal.
Wenn ihr das persönlich für wichtig haltet
und da ein paar Euro abgeben wollt,
ist das euer Ding.
Und ich kann euch nur aus eigener Erfahrung
sagen,
es gibt einem in gewisser Weise auch ein bisschen
was an...
Man freut sich ja auch irgendwo dann
danach. Also zumindest habe ich das öfters.
Wenn ich sehe, dass
die Kohle dann auch was bewirkt hat,
dann freut einen das auch.
Achso, ich habe...
Weißt du, was ich zuerst gelesen habe?
Ich habe zuerst gelesen,
die Firma möchte euch 10% weniger Geld bezahlen
und erzählt euch irgendwas mit.
Wir würden das Geld spenden.
Ja, ich auch, ich auch.
Deswegen mache ich das nicht.
Ja, und wenn ich das lokal spende,
wenn ich das lokal spende,
dann sehe ich ja auch, was damit passiert.
Außerdem sieht man dann direkt,
und das ist ja auch irgendwo ein bisschen was wert,
dass die Leute sich freuen darüber.
Das sieht man bei irgendwelchen anonymen,
ja, großen Organisationen
bei irgendeiner Überweisung nicht.
Da kriegst du dann eine Quittung, so nach dem Motto
Oh ja, wir bedanken uns für ihr Vertrauen, blablabla.
Aber ansonsten
nix.
Und
egal, wo ich bisher was gespendet habe,
die haben sich alle immer sichtlich
gefreut. Ich habe ja nicht nur...
Ich habe denen beispielsweise auch schon Katzenfutter gespendet,
vorbeigebracht, alles.
Gut, dann lasst uns mal die aktuellen
Shit-Hub-Trends angucken.
Leute, ich hatte...
Mir ist letztens was eingefallen, ja.
Wenn man anstatt Git Shit
sagt, müsste man dann
eigentlich nicht anstatt Gandalf auch
Shandalf sagen?
Ich weiß, sehr wirrer Gedanke, aber
letztens ist mir das irgendwie so eingefallen.
Ich glaube aber...
Ich glaube aber mit Shandalf fangen wir nicht an, ey.
Fragt mich nicht,
wie ich drauf gekommen bin, ey.
So, was trendet denn Weekly?
Sheld, genau. Das ist doch nicht Geld, ey.
Das ist Sheld.
Ja, genau.
Sheld finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Okay, was trendet denn?
Was trendet denn auf Shit-Hub so?
Diese Woche.
Authentic
Stranded.
Das ist ja mal sogar was, was ich kenne.
ES Toolkit.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was ist das?
Warum ist es nicht written in Rust?
So, weil es JavaScript selbst ist.
Okay, dann verstehe ich.
Okay, es ist JavaScript
Zeug, was im Browser laufen muss.
Weil ansonsten hätte ich gedacht,
die ganzen JavaScript-Leute, die bauen doch aktuell
alles in Rust, was in Rust zu bauen geht.
Stimmt, es ist nicht blazingly fast.
Es ist nur 2-3
times faster und up to
97% smaller.
Okay, Microsoft AI Zeug.
AI, AI, AI.
Nee, nicht AI. Downloader.
Das heißt trendet.
Wahnsinn.
C++, Ronke S.
Komm, wir gucken uns mal an, ob das schön ist oder hässlich ist.
C++ ist okay schon.
Wenn ich irgendwelche M4-Makro-Gedöns lese,
da weiß ich schon Bescheid.
Source.
Wow.
Alter.
Warum hat ein Download-Manager
so
ultra 30 Milliarden
Files, Mann.
The fuck.
Dependencies hier.
Peace, Peace CC. Okay, alles klar.
Ich hab Battlefield gelesen gerade.
Das ist ja...
Okay,
ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist ja sogar
ziemlich gut lesbares
C++, aber C++
ist irgendwie fast nie lesbar.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
UV.
Extremely fast Python Package Manager
and Project Manager written in Rust.
Oh nee, Leute. Das ist nicht nur das
Java-Ökosystem, wo die
ganzen Krustentiere alles rewriten.
Jetzt geht's mit Python weiter.
Das heißt,
pip ist outdated, UV ist jetzt angesagt.
Ich kann das aber verstehen.
Pip hatte ich bisher nie den Eindruck,
dass das ein richtig ordentlicher Package Manager ist.
Single-Tool-Replaced.
Pip.
Poetry, PyEnv,
Virtual Env, Pip-Tools.
Alles wird alles replaced.
Blazing Liefer...
Ist das denn Blazing...
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Er ist nur Extremely fast.
Chat, was ist denn
faster? Blazing
Liefer oder Extremely fast?
Kann mich da nicht entscheiden.
Ich würde sagen Blazing
Liefer bedeutet nur, dass
der manchmal sehr schnell ist
und Extremely fast heißt,
er ist immer sehr schnell.
Extremely Blazing Liefer.
Ja, das gibt's bestimmt
auch bald noch. Dann muss er
written in Sig sein. Ey, aber...
I3...
Äh, I3 Nachbau
genöns für Mac.
Auf deinem Mainboard steht Blazing Liefer.
Ist das auch? Ist sein Mainboard written in Rust?
Intel hat sich auch
gedacht, ihre CPUs sind demnächst
sind aktuell written in Rust, oder?
Ja.
Okay, ich bin nicht der Einzige, der auf diese blöde Idee
gekommen ist gerade.
Ja, die letzten zwei Intel CPU-Generationen
sind auch written in Rust.
Die sind tatsächlich
CPU-technisch doch durchaus
Blazingly fast.
So ein 13900K ist immer noch ziemlich schnell.
Aber die rosten halt.
Ich habe übrigens ein BIOS-Update gemacht
mittlerweile.
BIOS-Update, by the way.
Hat alles gut funktioniert.
Ich musste meine Settings neu
machen, das stimmt. Aber ansonsten
war es keinerlei Problem.
Gab es... War es keinerlei
Problem. Gab es keinerlei Probleme.
Das Wubblos-Archiv wurde
überarbeitet, da weiß ich gar nichts von.
Nee, das sieht immer noch genauso aus
wie das letzte Mal, oder?
Nee, Moment. Moment, das sieht nicht
genauso aus wie das letzte Mal.
Das sieht anders aus.
Modke, der ist
unser... Nee, ist nicht da.
Der Serious Max entwickelt das.
Das ist richtig nice.
Vor allem ist das
auch powered by AI.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt.
Also
das extrahiert ja aus jedem Video
ein...
Wie nennt man das? Transcript?
Dass man den Inhalt sogar durchsuchen
kann. Also das ist wirklich
Next Level High IQ Shit.
Und eine Zeit lang
wurden sogar für die
Streams, aber das hat er anscheinend wieder
ausgebaut, wurden für die
Streams sogar AI
Thumbnails
generiert. Aber das hat er wieder
rausgeschmissen. Was auch durchaus sinnig
ist, da sieht man wenigstens was im Stream passiert.
Weil AI
kann ja auch manchmal, wenn das automatisch
hochgeladet ist, merkwürdiges Zeug generieren.
So, haben wir sonst noch irgendwas
spannendes diese Woche?
Nee, das ist ja echt nicht so...
nicht so nice,
was da trendet diese Woche.
Zum größten Teil relativ
unspektakulär. Ich frag
mich, was das hier eigentlich genau sein soll.
A Modern
JavaScript Utility
Library.
Achso, ja.
Habe ich nicht sowas letztens bei
Deno auch gesehen? Hatte Deno
nicht letztens ein Video hochgeladen? Sie
haben jetzt eine neue JavaScript
Standard Library? Das ist
nicht zufällig das hier, oder?
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie das alte Eclipse
Logo. Falls sich jemand noch
an Eclipse erinnern kann.
Kann sich noch jemand an Eclipse erinnern?
So eines der
painst champigen Idees, die es je
gegeben hat. Der alten Arbeit.
Also, letzter Job, wo ich
zuletzt vor
eineinhalb Jahren gewesen bin.
Ein Java-Entwickler
dort. Der hat bis zum Schluss Eclipse verwendet.
Alle anderen schon lange auf
IntelliJ am Start.
Aber der
hat an Eclipse
der hing an
Eclipse. Der wollte einfach immer nur
Eclipse verwenden. Und wir hatten
auch einen, der hat Dings verwendet.
Wie heißt nochmal der dritte
im Bunde? Es gab mal drei
große JavaScript, äh, nicht
JavaScript, fuck. Java Idees.
Es gab Eclipse, danach
ein bisschen, da gab es irgendwann mal auch IntelliJ.
IntelliJ war, glaube ich, die letzte
der großen drei da. Und dann gab
es noch, wie heißt denn das andere Ding?
Das, das,
das war ein ganz anderer Name.
Tomcat, ne, NetBeans.
NetBeans. Ja, genau, Chatge.
NetBeans. Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
NetBeans?
Oracle. Okay, okay.
Direkt weg.
Direkt weg damit.
NetBeans gibt es noch, okay.
Das hat ein anderer verwendet.
Aber die meisten sind auf IntelliJ hängen geblieben.
Verständlicherweise, wir
hier im Stream sind ja auch
indirekt auf IntelliJ hängen geblieben.
Wir verwenden allerdings nicht IntelliJ,
wir verwenden die ganzen anderen Jetbrain Idees,
die aber unter der Haube
sicherlich auf sau viel
von dem, was IntelliJ als Grundstein
mitgelegt hat, verwendet.
Ja, ich meine selbst, wenn
wir hier unsere, unsere .NET
Idee aufmachen, wir entwickeln
streng genommen ja hier mit Rider
entwickeln wir .NET in Java.
Also das ist eine Java-based IDE
für .NET.
Eigentlich auch ziemlich
weirdchamp. Ja.
Bisschen,
bisschen große,
bisschen große Schriftart, oder?
Ey, Paypal trinkt gerade Kaffee.
Das mache ich auch mal. Weil ich trinke keinen Kaffee,
ich trinke meinen Tee, aber
hydrated stayen müssen wir, Leute.
Aber Eclipse wird doch gar nicht mehr großartig
weiterentwickelt, oder?
Wird Eclipse überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Repository
Storys.
Leute, ich weiß noch nicht mal, welches der
Repos überhaupt jetzt Eclipse sein soll.
Was da? Okay.
Er wird tatsächlich
Es wird tatsächlich
an Eclipse noch rumeditiert.
Wahnsinn.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Ich dachte, das ist komplett
aus... Ja, hier.
2024. Fuck. Das ist tatsächlich
Das ist tatsächlich noch ziemlich aktuell.
Eclipse
Con. What the fuck?
Da gibt es da eine Konferenz.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich dachte, das ist deutlich weniger
verbreitet mittlerweile.
Chatge, ganzen Java-Hackermans
unter euch, haben wir noch
Eclipse-Enjoyer? Wenn, dann ist es noch
jemand? Ich meine, wenn die eine
eigene Konferenz machen,
eins, zwei, drei
Tage lang, dann
muss das ja noch irgendjemand verwenden. Die machen
auch keine Konferenz für drei User auf der Welt.
Sachen gibt es. Warum
haben wir eigentlich Bootstrap hier die ganze Zeit
offen? Was nicht mehr Twitter-
Bootstrap ist.
Was aber im Namen noch so aussieht.
Und es ist auch schon lange kein Twitter mehr
war. Schon lange bevor
TwitterX geworden ist, schon kein Twitter
mehr war. Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir
aufgefallen ist? Windows
hat was umgestellt. Normalerweise konnte man hier unten immer
die User wechseln. Jetzt kann man die User
nicht mehr wechseln. Jetzt muss man auf den User
klicken und dann hier oben
und dann auf Switch User.
Warum macht man es eigentlich so abartig
umständlich immer? Achso,
ja, wahrscheinlich, weil lokaler Account, lokaler
Account ist ja von Microsoft nicht gewollt.
Ja, schon.
Aber, na, wobei, ja,
wobei, ich mein,
ganz ehrlich,
bei den neuen Sachen ist es doch oft mal so,
ja, man hat erstmal ein bisschen Abneigung
dagegen, weil es was Neues ist, wenn man sich was Neues angucken
muss. Aber oftmals, wenn man dann mal angefangen
hat, das so nebenbei testweise zu benutzen,
erkennt man dann die Vorteile, falls es die
dann gibt, und bleibt dann eher da drauf
hängen. Sonst würde ich immer noch
WIM benutzen den ganzen Tag.
Für alles. Es gibt ja Leute,
für die ist das der heilige Kral,
den ganzen Tag WIM zu benutzen, aber
ich bin ja weg davon, für alles
und jedes WIM zu benutzen.
Ich hatte, ich hatte nen WIM, der war
customised, der hatte was weiß ich, wie viele tausend
Zeilen WIMRC und Plugins und Geschiss.
Das war mir einfach
komplett
übertrieben. Mittlerweile bin ich weg davon.
Ich verwende WIM täglich zum Editieren
für kleinere Sachen, die man halt
auf der Kommandozeile macht, jetzt hier irgendwie, wenn ich sag
hier, was weiß ich, muss ich irgendwas
editieren, dann zack, hier wird das
Terminal schnell aufgemacht. Aber sobald es irgendein
größeres Projekt ist,
dann wird das entweder
in Visual Studio Code oder in einem der
Jetbrain IDE's aufgemacht.
Ja, das können wir tatsächlich
jetzt auch gleich gucken.
NKG, danke schon für den Sub.
Ne, das hast du nicht verpasst, das haben wir
sogar noch irgendwo auf. Welches ist denn das?
Das da, meinst du,
gell? Google
accidentally
sprich man das richtig aus.
Accidentally? Accidentally.
Deletes 135
Billion,
was halt Ami-Billions
sind.
Also was Milliarden
bei uns ist, aber halt immer noch ziemlich viel Geld.
Davon könnte man ja fast
Modern Snake 2.0 finanzieren.
Ne, das haben wir nicht geguckt, aber
das können wir uns klar angucken.
Hast du mal Z ausprobiert? Ja, hab ich.
Aber das crasht immer
bei mir in der VM. Wollen wir mal ausprobieren?
Ob es mittlerweile wieder geht?
Ich mach mal kurz einen Snapshot.
Weil das immer tausendfaches
Zeug da ist.
Ups.
Mal gucken, ob das
jetzt mittlerweile funktioniert.
Das liegt aber an meiner VM.
Das ist höchstwahr...
Ich hab das jetzt installiert
und... Okay, da ist es.
Wie heißt denn das?
Z-Editor.
Das geht einfach gar nicht.
Äh...
Warum ging's da nicht?
Ja, das ist ein Binary, das ist auch klar.
Aber...
Das läuft bei mir nicht.
Das liegt garantiert an...
Ja, natürlich ist der durch.
Sonst wär der ja noch da.
Kannst ja nochmal reinstallen.
Das geht schnell. Arch, by the way.
Es läuft bei mir nicht.
Das liegt ziemlich sicher an der VM.
Und dass das Vulkan braucht,
dass es funktioniert.
Ich kann übrigens mal die Snapshots löschen,
weil ich reverte einfach auf diesen Snapshot.
Yes.
Bevor ich das installiert hab.
Und dann schmeißen wir aber die ganzen Snapshots weg.
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
Hast du mal NixOS probiert?
Nee.
Aber ich hab den Nix Package Manager installiert.
Kann man den Nix Package Manager updaten
über NixOS... äh, über Nix, über den Nix Package Manager?
Kann er sich selbst updaten?
Ja, wir sind mittlerweile
schon so weit, dass es eigentlich...
Dass Arch, by the way, nur noch Meme ist
und die richtig krassen, nicen Hackermans
eigentlich NixOS verwenden.
Und, by the way, das allen erzählen müssen,
dass sie NixOS usen.
I use NixOS, by the way.
Wie gesagt, ich mach das nicht mit dem...
mit dem Archiv.
Oh, High-Speed Snapshot Deleting.
Nix unter Arch.
Ja, hab ich.
Das geht.
NixOS sind ja mehrere Sachen.
Unter anderem kannst du NixOS verwenden
oder du kannst den Nix Package Manager verwenden
und ich verwende den unter Arch.
By the way.
Nix, by the way, unter Arch, by the way.
Na, Ubuntu ist nix zum by the way'n.
By the way, mein Vater
verwendet immer noch Linux Mint
und
kommt damit soweit auch klar.
Na gut, aktuell nicht. Aktuell ist er gerade im Krankenhaus.
Aber,
wenn er es verwendet, kommt er damit klar.
Also, so
schlecht kann das für Einsteiger nicht sein.
Was hab ich denn in dem
Snapshot alles drin, bzw. was hab ich denn
alles nach diesem Snapshot gemacht?
Snapshots speichern ja nur Diffs.
Die wären richtig fett mit der Zeit.
Verwendest du Bogen-Linux?
Ja, das ist nice. Bogen-Linux ist
pock. Also, ich hab meinem Vater
Linux Mint Cinnamon Edition
draufgehauen auf so ein Mini-PC
und im Prinzip
hat er auf seinem Desktop, hat er nun ein Chrome-Icon
und ein
LibreOffice Writer.
Da hat er auch schon
festgestellt, das ist ja wie Word.
Ja, das kenn ich.
So, zack, da sind wir wieder.
Selbst FireShip Hype NixOS
jetzt, das hab ich gesehen, da hat ein Video hochgeladen zu.
Ja, hab ich sogar
schon offen.
Aber wir gucken uns jetzt das an. Stimmt, das haben wir schon seit Wochen
offen und wollen uns das angucken.
2024,
okay, es ist sogar was halbwegs aktuelles.
Dann lasst uns das doch mal angucken.
Also, Google löscht ausversehen
135 Milliarden Pensionsfund.
Wie kann man
Chaos End Use, wie kann man das übersetzen?
Ähm,
weiter geht's
mit Durcheinander oder
Durcheinander
setzt sich fort
oder, wie kann man das übersetzen
gescheit? Chaotische Zustände.
Chaotische Zustände
sind glaube ich, ist glaube ich
Chaotische Zustände sind glaube ich
ist glaube ich eine gute deutsche Übersetzung
dafür.
Oi!
...
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, um was es geht.
Das ist die Geschichte, wo Google einfach das Projekt gelöscht hat.
Von den Leuten.
Ja, stimmt, das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Das ist, das ist, ja, das ist schon
ein, zwei Monate her.
Die hatten glücklicherweise Backups
von ihrem Zeug.
It's gone. Crikey.
Let's rewind one year to see exactly
how we got to this situation.
On May 1st, 2023,
the Google Cloud VMware Engine
or GCVE team was enjoying
their free team massage when they
received a ticket from one of their customers.
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
...
welches man dann im Vertrieb ausbauen kann.
Als Amerikaner scheint dies ähnlich zu dem 401k, das wir hier haben, zu funktionieren.
Jedenfalls baut Unisuper ihre Software aufgrund von VMware,
welches eine Plattform ist, die Lösungen bietet, um on-premises Cloud-Umgebungen zu bauen.
Ich bilde mir ein, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Vielleicht habe ich das auch schon gesehen, ohne euch. Das könnte natürlich sein.
Wenn ihr all die coolen Cloud-Fähigkeiten möchtet, wie die Fähigkeit, virtuelle Maschinen zu spinnen,
Autoscalen, Lade-Balance, Failover, Provision-Storage, Database, Container
und habt all diese Sachen zusammen integriert,
aber ihr wollt nicht mit Big Cloud handeln,
könnt ihr eure eigene Hardware bekommen und private Cloud-Software runtern,
wie VMware, CloudStack oder OpenStack, auf dem ihr die gleiche Erfahrung bekommt.
Aber am Ende findet ihr heraus, dass Big Cloud eigentlich ziemlich gut ist.
Und einige eurer Freunde sind sogar auf Big Cloud eingegangen.
Also spinnt ihr das Rad, um zu entscheiden, welches zu benutzen,
und migriert einiges dazu.
Ich gehe eigentlich prinzipiell nur noch in die AliExpress-Cloud.
Aber ihr wollt euch nicht hinter den ganzen Vmware-Tooling verlassen,
mit dem ihr sich gewohnt habt.
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt, das könnt ihr mir doch nicht erzählen, dass das neu ist.
Das haben wir doch schon gesehen.
Oder bin ich jetzt komplett verwirrt?
Oder habe ich das alleine geguckt?
Kann auch sein, dass ich das alleine geguckt habe.
... Cloud hat bereits dein Anwendungsfall besucht.
Mit Google Clouds Vmware-Engine kannst du deine Vmware-basierten Applikationen
ohne Änderungen zu deinen Apps, Tools oder Prozessen anbieten.
Jetzt kannst du dich zurückhalten und relaxieren,
als du deine Vmware-Tools anbietest.
Das haben die doch garantiert nur gemacht,
dass du das irgendwelchen Managern zeigen kannst und die sagen,
oh ja, da können wir das alles in der Cloud betreiben,
ohne dass wir uns sonst Gedanken machen müssen.
Weil in der Regel ist einfaches, wir haben on-prem eine VM,
wir wollen aber in die Cloud und was machen wir?
Wir kopieren einfach die VM, so wie sie ist, in die Cloud.
Meistens so ziemlich der schlechteste Weg,
Sachen in die Cloud zu packen, denen es sie gibt.
Und auch der teuerste, öfters, oftmals, nicht immer, aber oftmals.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass das genau der Grund ist,
warum das Google anbietet, weil die wissen, es gibt da einen Markt für.
Ich meine, es gibt ganz viele Unternehmen,
die eine lokale Vmware-Installation haben und sagen,
ja, wir würden das aber gerne, anstatt bei uns irgendwo in der Cloud,
... anstatt bei uns irgendwo in der Cloud, ... anstatt bei uns irgendwo in der Cloud, ... anstatt bei uns irgendwo in der Cloud,
... anstatt bei uns irgendwo in der Cloud, ... anstatt bei uns irgendwo in der Cloud, ... betreiben.
Aber so dieses Neuausdenken, wie betreiben wir das denn jetzt?
Und wie können wir vielleicht daraus Container machen?
Oder wie können wir vielleicht das zusammenfassen?
Da haben die keinen Bock drauf.
... without changes to your apps, tools or processes.
Now you can sit back and relax as you hand your infrastructure over
for a small fee of 5.11 per hour over three years.
But then you discover that the private cloud you need for your service
has special capacity requirements, ...
... which cannot be provisioned.
using the publicly available Google Cloud Interface.
Ja, dann gehst du zu Google und sagst,
Google, ich würde gerne meine eigenen Sachen bei euch hosten.
Das geht ja.
Also du kannst dir ja quasi eine eigene SX-Installation machen lassen.
Wir haben uns auf der Arbeit tatsächlich mal kurzzeitig so was überlegt,
weil wir viel lokalen SSD-Storage brauchen,
aber da hatte Google nix so richtig passendes.
... Cloud Interface.
So you contact Google, ...
Also ich hab das gesehen, ich halte davon nix, weil in der Regel,
also ich hab das beim letzten Arbeitgeber gesehen,
weil in der Regel ist das so, es gibt eine Master-Excel-Liste.
Warum Excel?
Weil es immer Excel ist.
Es gibt eine Master-Excel-Liste, da steht drin,
diese Systeme haben wir on-prem, die muss umgezogen werden
und wenn die, wenn die, wenn ich es ganz ernst mein,
haben die da noch irgendeine Deadline hinten dran stehen,
so bis wann das umgezogen werden muss.
Und als erstes werden die einfachen Systeme umgezogen
und auch mit der einfachsten Variante, die es gibt.
Das heißt, man nimmt die Systeme, die eh problemlos laufen,
packt sie einfach in eine Cloud-VM und sagt fertig.
Und dann laufen die in der Cloud.
Niemand fasst diese Systeme jemals wieder an.
Der Aufwand ist viel zu groß zu sagen, ey,
...
Wir haben das jetzt ja in die Cloud umgezogen, weil, weil,
und das ist der eigentliche Punkt,
weil es geht bei sowas ja nicht darum,
eine sinnvolle Infrastruktur zu bauen,
ja, die zu der Anwendung passt, die man betreibt.
Es geht darum, den, ähm, dem Managementwunsch,
es muss in die Cloud Genüge zu tun.
Das ist ja der Grund, das ist ja der, der, der, der,
der Gedanke hinter solchen Excel-Listen.
Es geht nicht darum zu sagen, okay,
wir wollen eine sinnvolle Cloud-Infrastruktur aufbauen
für unseren Anwendungsbetrieb und dazu machen wir das.
Nee, nee, es geht darum, dass die Excel-Liste
bis zum nächsten Abteilungsmeeting zu, äh, abgearbeitet ist.
Niemand fasst es danach jemals wieder an.
Das heißt, wenn man erst mal damit anfängt,
VMs einfach in die Cloud zu kopieren,
werden die immer in der Cloud laufen.
Zu 90 Prozent.
Und das ist halt, das Problem haste, by the way,
wenn Entscheidungsleute keinen Plan von der Technik haben,
... beziehungsweise ...
... nicht auf die Leute hören, die Plan von der Technik haben,
dann kommen solche komischen Dinger bei raus.
Ich will in die Cloud, wie ist mir egal?
Ja, gut, dann kopieren wir halt die VMs.
Ja, okay, macht mal, ist mir egal, Hauptsache in der Cloud.
Es ist oftmals gar, also die schlechtmöglichste
Infrastrukturentscheidung, das so zu machen.
Es gibt viel, es gibt viel sinnvollere Möglichkeiten,
wenn man eh schon am Umbauen ist, die man zumindest mal in Erwägung ziehen sollte,
... wenn man eh schon am Umbauen ist, die man zumindest mal in Erwägung ziehen sollte,
... viele Anwendungen sind so klein und, sagen wir mal, Eidellastig,
... dass du die wahrscheinlich in den Container packen könntest,
... wenn du nicht, brauchst du nicht mal ein Managed Kubernetes,
... du kannst es als einzelnen Container laufen lassen,
... du kannst es als Cloud-Function vielleicht sogar laufen lassen,
... die wird fünfmal im Monat aufgerufen,
... und selbst mit nem Cold Start haben die meisten dann nicht mal Probleme.
Es gibt ja so viele kleine spezialisierte Dinger.
... und selbst mit nem Cold Start haben die meisten dann nicht mal Probleme. Es gibt ja so viele kleine spezialisierte Dinger,
Ist eine VM mit dem...
Das ist einfach eine blöde Idee.
Das war es on-prem schon, aber da ging es halt nicht anders.
An der Cloud hast du mehr Möglichkeiten.
Und das wird nie passieren.
Das Ding wird eins zu eins umgezogen in die Cloud
und dann läuft es da und läuft es da für immer.
Ihr kennt ja die Story vom wahren Wirtschaftssystem,
das eigentlich ein Red Hat 4 ist
und unter Red Hat 6 läuft
und sich als Red Hat 5 ausgibt.
Habe ich euch jetzt ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Solche Dinger kommen dann da zusammen.
Wenn man so Legacy-Sachen,
ohne sich Gedanken drüber zu machen,
einfach nur von System zu System kopiert.
Und alles fängt oftmals an mit irgendeiner Master-Excel-Liste,
die auf irgendeiner Abteilungsrunde,
Abteilungsversammlung, was auch immer,
Führungskräfte-Meeting zusammengeschustert wurde,
weil irgendein Sales-Typ von Microsoft
bei eurem Chef war,
bei eurem Chef-Chef-Chef war
und der jetzt davon ganz angetan ist.
Okay.
Wir gucken weiter.
Also ich bin kein Fan von,
man kopiert es im ersten Schritt einfach die VM in die Cloud,
weil in der Regel bleibt die VM dann für immer in der Cloud,
so wie sie ist.
Eins zu eins.
Plus, dass je nachdem, wie du es machst,
du in der Cloud auch keinerlei Möglichkeiten mehr hast,
deinen klassischen Update-Zyklus
oder dein klassisches Change-Management
ordentlich zu betreiben.
Viele Leute haben für On-Prem-Kisten
einen etablierten Workflow
von einem Server mit neuesten RPM-Packages drauf.
Es wird, keine Ahnung, alle drei Wochen mal geupdatet und sowas.
Sobald das Ding in die Cloud umgezogen wurde,
fällt es instant weg.
Anderes Netzwerk, andere Handhabung,
sodass die VM im schlimmsten Fall
sogar noch ein großes Sicherheitsrisiko irgendwann birgt.
Weil das Ding dann wirklich nur einmalig umgezogen wird
und nie wieder was passiert mit.
They can do.
This is what this has special capacity requirements,
which cannot be provisioned using the publicly available Google Cloud.
So you contact Google to see what they can do.
This is what Unisuper did.
Heute muss ich eine Stunde vierzig rennen.
Long run, sagt mein Uhr, by the way.
Fällt mir nur gerade so auf.
And Google's VMware Engine Team
had just received their request.
The engineers reviewed the ticket
and decided that they could move forward
by deploying this special cloud
using an internal tool
that can deploy VMware Engine Clouds for customers.
They filled in the parameters
for account region hardware specs
and hopefully,
ran it by a second engineer
prior to executing it
as part of their internal control protocols.
Everything looked good
and they ran the command.
Unisuper then saw
Das hat irgendein Google-Typ
jetzt kurz vor Mittagessen mal gemacht, oder wie?
that everything was provisioned correctly
and everyone was happy.
For now.
Fast forward one year later,
on May 1st, 2024,
the Unisuper devs noticed
that one of their key services
stopped responding.
Effe!
Das ganze Service und die Cloud,
in der es gegründet wurde,
scheint nicht mehr zu existieren.
Das war ziemlich seltsam,
weil die Audit-Logs
keine Anleitungen gezeigt haben,
und private Clouds
verletzen sich normalerweise nicht.
In jedem Fall,
ob es ihre Schuld war oder nicht,
mussten sie sobald möglich
bis zum Ende des Prozesses kommen.
Der Website war komplett nicht funktionierbar,
bis das geschlossen wurde.
Nicht zu erwähnen,
dass der gesamte Stack
von sowohl Computerkapazität
als auch Daten verloren wurde
und die finanzielle Daten,
für über 100 Billionen Dollar
wertvolle Anleitungen,
ziemlich schlecht sein könnten.
Also riefen die Ingenieure sofort
nach Google,
um zu fragen, was da los war.
Und die Googlers
haben ihre internen API-Logs
beobachtet.
Ich sag euch, was passiert ist.
Die haben ein Ticket bei Google aufgemacht
und die erste Antwort war,
Hallo, ich bin Peter vom Google Support.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden,
dass sie Verbindungsprobleme haben
zu ihrer Cloud-4M Instanz?
Ja, genau.
Wir empfehlen,
einen Verbindungscheck durchzuführen
mit diesen Kommandos
gcloud login bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
nslookup und ping.
Wenn das ihre Probleme behoben hat,
bitte Ticket schließen.
Das ist die erste Response,
die vom Google Support kam.
Könnte ich wetten.
Weil egal, ob es der Google Support ist
oder Microsoft Azure Support
oder sonst was,
die haben alle den Hang dazu,
bei der ersten Ticket-Response
eigentlich deine Frage
nur noch mal zu wiederholen
und ein paar Textbausteine drunter zu setzen.
Und warum ist das Ganze so?
Naja, weil die eben Response-Time,
wie nennt man das?
SLA sind es ja nicht wirklich.
So Response-Time-Agreements irgendwie haben.
Also nach dem Motto,
erste Reaktion aufs Ticket erfolgt
innerhalb von 12 Stunden,
24 Stunden, 8 Stunden, whatever.
Deswegen ist die erste Reaktion
eigentlich nur dazu da,
um den Vertrag zu erfüllen,
nicht um was Sinnvolles zu machen.
Zumindest drängt sich mir das immer auf,
wenn ich die ersten Antworten von Tickets sehe.
Und das ist eigentlich fast egal,
ob das bei Oracle ist,
bei Red Hat ist,
bei Microsoft ist,
bei Google ist.
Das ist gefühlt überall so.
Sie sahen, dass es automatisch ausgelöst wurde,
wegen seiner ein Jahr langen Auslösung.
Das war ungewöhnlich,
da diese Art von Autodeletion-Behörde
nicht möglich war,
in einer typischen Kunden-kreativen Cloud zu erreichen.
Nach weiterer Investition haben sie herausgefunden,
dass genau ein Jahr her, an diesem Tag,
die Unisuper-Cloud manuell von Google-Ingenieuren
mit einem internen Tool kreiert wurde.
Alles war korrekt,
außer es verlor einen wichtigen Parameter.
Ich kann nicht spezifizieren,
was dieser Missing-Parameter war,
aber weil es missging,
wurde die private Cloud mit dem Default-Behörde
des automatischen Auslöses
nach einem Jahr kreiert.
Der Verstörende der Applikations-Komponenten
wird ziemlich einfach sein.
Sie haben einfach...
Ich kann euch sagen,
also ich rate,
ich rate jetzt einfach mal.
Dieses Tool ist wahrscheinlich dafür gedacht,
irgendwelche internen Sachen zu testen
und damit sich nicht mal was getestet wird
und sich Infrastruktur quasi
auftürmt durch irgendwelche Tests,
wo die Leute vergessen oder zu faul sind zu löschen,
haben die standardmäßig einen Timeout eingebaut von einem Jahr.
So nach dem Motto,
ey, wenn es nach einem Jahr noch nicht abgeschlossen ist,
der Test, dann kann es ja nicht mehr so wichtig sein.
Bam, weg.
Wahrscheinlich war dieses Tool niemals dafür gedacht,
dass man damit irgendwelche Endkunden-Sachen anlegt.
We had to re-provision the infrastructure
and deploy the code,
all with existing tooling.
However, getting all the data back
was going to require a lot of manual work
and some novel automation coded up.
In some circumstances,
data can be restored using a replica or production stack
in a different availability zone
that wasn't subject to erasure.
However, this was not possible here
since their entire cloud,
which spanned both of their zones,
holding all of their production data,
was deleted.
They were saved, however-
Gut, dass sie Backups hatten, das weiß ich.
Das habe ich auf Reddit damals gelesen.
Because they backed up their data.
Auf Hacker News gelesen.
Not only did they have backups in Google Cloud Storage,
which was a separate server,
unrelated to the deleted cloud,
but they also had backups with a different provider.
As the two companies worked together
to get the service back up and running,
the customers began complaining.
This was reasonable,
as they could no longer access or view their funds,
and there was also fear of regarding it
being a potential cyber attack.
Little did they know,
Unisuper just had their app...
Es ist schon ein bisschen kacke,
wenn du denkst, meine Rente ist weg, oder?
Das würde mich etwas nervös machen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
An der Stelle von den Australiern,
die dort ihr Geld reingesteckt haben.
Du wachst morgens auf, willst mal gucken,
so ey, wie viel Rente kriege ich eigentlich,
und meine Rente ist weg.
Das würde mich etwas beunruhigen.
Minimal.
Location deleted by a third party,
and they could literally do nothing about it.
They reassured their users by releasing a statement,
saying there was an issue originating from one of their
third party service providers,
and that it wasn't a malicious attack.
Then the statement was updated to release...
$100Kon,
und...
daraufhin hat er sich erschossen.
Und einen Tag später kam eine Mail,
dass das ein Abrechnungsfehler war und er plusminus null ist.
Schon scheiße, ne?
Solche Dinger, solche Zahlen, die online angezeigt werden.
Die können wir auf Reddit gucken, ob ihr das findet.
Keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Es war erst gestern wieder auf Reddit.
Auf Reddit steht auch viel Mist, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ja genau, der war auch nicht alt.
Ja.
Also ich bin nicht der Einzige, der das gelesen hat.
Vielleicht sollte man keine internen Tools, die nicht für Live-Umgebung gedacht sind, dafür verwenden.
Da gehe ich von aus, ja.
Genau das dachte ich mir auch, ja.
Ja, klar.
Okay, soweit in der Theorie.
Macht das in der Praxis jemand?
Also ich habe nicht 3, 2, 1.
Ich habe eher 2.
Rate zählt ja nicht.
Ich habe 2, 1, 0 vielleicht.
Aber es hat doch den Eindruck gemacht, als hat Google das echt ganz gut gehandelt, oder?
Man erst mal rauskriegen, was ist.
Dann internifizieren, was gemacht werden muss.
Das Ganze wieder restauren.
Weil man könnte sich jetzt ein bisschen drüber streiten, sind 2 Wochen nicht vielleicht ein bisschen lang.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, nachdem es sicherlich nicht einfacher ist, rauszufinden, was, wie, wo, wie, wer.
Würde ich sagen, lief das doch noch den Umständen entsprechend gut, oder?
Was sagt ihr?
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass das eine KI-Stimme ist.
Der Kel hört sich schon immer so an.
Hier, guck mal, hier gab es.
Da gab es noch keine KI-Stimme.
Und das hört sich damals schon so an.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Cat-Content.
Also, dass ich da nicht rein will.
Okay, gut, wichtig, richtig und wichtig, dass wir das jetzt gesehen haben.
Weep OS.
FireShip.
Habt ihr eure Backups schon mal benötigt?
Ja.
Habe ich.
Also, sowohl im Professional-Umfeld schon öfters.
Äh, privat auch schon.
Aber privat, witzigerweise, ich glaube, das einzige Mal, wo ich privat die Updates wirklich benötigt habe.
Lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Ähm.
Ja, ne, ich glaube.
Naja, also, ich glaube, das einzige Mal, wo ich Backups wirklich benötigt war, benötigt hatte, ist, ähm, als eine externe Festplatte mal nicht lesbar war.
Da habe ich Gameplay-Material, also auch noch nicht mal was wirklich Wichtiges, da habe ich Gameplay-Material drauf gespeichert, was doof ist, wenn es weg ist, also in Zeiten, wo ich noch öfters YouTube-Videos gemacht habe.
Und da war die externe Festplatte nicht mehr lesbar.
Aber ich hatte es glücklicherweise schon auf mein Netzwerk-Share kopiert.
Das war aber, glaube ich, echt das Einzige.
Ne, das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe schon mal alte Dateien, die ich mal irgendwie vor, keine Ahnung, sieben Jahren oder so wusste, dass ich die auf dem Rechner hatte.
Die habe ich schon mal irgendwie...
...backup gemountet, durchsucht.
Aber selten, ganz selten.
Also, ich sage mal so, auf der Arbeit kommt das wöchentlich mehrfach vor.
So nach dem Motto, hier, wir brauchen Datei sowieso, liegt im Backup.
Auf der Arbeit ist es ja sogar noch Band, zumindest.
Zumindest sind es die Tools noch von Band-Backup, Tape-Backups.
Ob das wirklich ein Tape-Backup drunter ist, weiß ich nicht, aber ich glaube schon.
Ist noch Band.
Erst vor ein paar Tagen wieder war es restored.
Irgendwelche Transaction-Dateien, die gefehlt haben und die mussten irgendwas kontrollieren und dann musste ich ins Backup-Archiv und irgendwelche Gigabytes an Transaction-Daten restauren, dass die reingucken konnten, ob das alles okay war an dem Tag oder so.
Keine Ahnung, was die da genau machen.
Das bin ich sehend.
Was ist da los?
Und überwacht ihr eure Backups?
Naja.
Ich mach einmal nachts in R-Sync auf ne externe Platte von meinem NAS.
Und, ja, ich hoffe das geht halt.
So wirklich, so wirklich irgendwie Timestamp, dann überwachen, Zabbix oder so, ob das dann auch das richtige Dateidatum hat, so mein ich.
Sollte ich vielleicht machen.
Vielleicht lief's ja schon ne Woche nicht mehr.
Wie sicher sind Bayerns Volksfälle?
So sicher wie alle anderen auch.
Also sicher oder nicht sicher wie alle anderen auch.
Glaubt nicht, dass das jetzt eben mit Bayern oder nicht Bayern was zu tun hat.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt das FireShip-Video an.
Mal gucken, was FireShip zu NixOS zu sagen hat.
Oder zu Nix.
Nicht zu NixOS.
Mal gucken.
NixOS sind ja zwei Sachen.
Einmal der Package Manager.
Und dann gibt's das Ganze auch noch als eigenes Betriebssystem, also quasi als so mehr oder weniger immutable Betriebssystem, wo du ne Config-Datei hast.
Die quasi beim Boot dein Betriebssystem so hinstellt, wie es sein soll.
Da gibt's nix zu zu sagen, genau.
Functional Package Manager Nix.
A purely functional Package Manager and System Configuration Tool that allows developers to say it works on my machine with absolute confidence.
It was created in 2003 by...
So alt ist das schon.
Ich hab bestimmt, also, keine Ahnung, die letzten drei, vier Jahre maximal, was von Nix gehört, davor nie.
Wie sieht's bei euch aus?
Also mir war nicht klar.
Dass es das schon seit 2003 gibt.
Ilko Dostra, who wrote his PhD thesis on a purely functional software deployment model.
Twenty years later, it's used by tons of software projects like Mozilla Firefox, Google's IDX, and of course NixOS, a complete Linux distro based on this Package Manager.
But why Nix?
When you set up your own Linux server, the default approach is to SSH into it and start running a bunch of commands that you copied from random places on the Internet.
The problem is that it quickly becomes impossible to reproduce the state of the system.
Also, ich habe mir mal angeguckt, wie ich eine funktionierende Entwicklungsumgebung für ein ESP32 mit NixOS mir hinstelle.
Und das war so kompliziert, dass ich es mir nicht weiter angeguckt habe.
Dieses File ist wie ein Blueprint, das jetzt die gleiche Maschine wiederholt und wiederholt.
Nun, alle Änderungen zu dieser Konfiguration sind transaktional oder atomisch, also alles funktioniert oder fehlt zusammen.
Ein großer Vorteil davon ist, dass wenn du etwas verpasst, kannst du es einfach zurückholen zu dem vorherigen Zustand.
Es ist wie eine Zeitmaschine für deine Maschine.
Das ist möglich, weil in der Nix-Store jedes Paket und seine Abhängigkeiten in einer separaten Direktorie sind,
die von einem einzigen kryptographischen Hash identifiziert wird, was garantiert, dass die Pakete nicht mit einander interferieren.
Und mit Nix-Shell kannst du die Nix-Store auswählen.
Jedes Format braucht irgendeinen spezial coolen Namen, oder?
Keine Gems, keine Cargo, keine...
Was war...
Okay, lass mal kurz überlegen, was kriegen wir aus dem Kopf zusammen, was es da so für Package-Formate gibt.
Äh, Gems ist es bei Ruby.
Äh, X...
Nee, heißt das nicht X bei Python?
Wie heißt das da?
Ist das nicht Eier?
Äh, Nugets bei .NET.
Äh, Cargo...
Cargo bei Rust.
RPM.
Crates.
Crates, nicht Cargos.
Crates bei Rust.
Ihr habt recht.
Cargos, Alter.
Cargo ist das Kommando zum Installieren, ja.
Flatpack?
Ja.
To get started, install the Nix Package Manager, or better yet, liveboot NixOS to try it out as a full Linux distro.
Inside the etc directory, you'll find a configuration.nix file.
You can think of this file as a function that returns a dictionary or hash map.
At the top, we have parameters for config,
which gives us access to the entire configuration,
and packages, which includes all the packages available on NixOS.
Next, with imports, we can break up our config into multiple smaller files to keep things organized.
But the real magic of Nix is being able to configure the entire system right here,
like set the bootloader to Grub2, or set the timezone to Arizona,
or add a user like Alice, who has pseudo-privileges.
Not only is that way more efficient than the user-add-command in Linux, but it's ex...
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
...blicit, declarative and reproducible.
Now, if I want to add a new package, like Metasploit, I can add it here and then run nixos-rebuild-switch.
This will download the package and all of its dependencies and rebuild the system.
Das ist wie Ansible, aber immutable Atomic.
Es ist immer so, die Ansible-Config-Files und das Nix...
Ja, das ist ähnlich.
Nur dass das bei Ansible halt einmal konfiguriert wird und dann immer nur drauf aufbaut.
Ja, wenn du bei Ansible was...
Rausschmeißt, dann bleibt es ja nach wie vor da.
Bei nixos wird das bei jedem Boot quasi neu angelegt.
Also bei nixos kannst du dir auch wirklich sicher sein, dass dein OS in dem Zustand ist, wie es in deiner Config-Datei steht, bei Ansible nicht wirklich.
Pretty cool, but what's really awesome is that if we made a mistake, we can list out all of the generations and then easily roll back to a previous version.
This has been nix in 100 seconds.
Amazing tools like this exist because good developers understand how to solve problems.
And you can start to solve problems.
We are developing your problem-solving skills for free today, thanks to this video's sponsor.
Brilliant.
It doesn't matter which Linux distro you use, but rather how...
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ja.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich bin jetzt genauso schlau wie vorher, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kann die Katzenvideos nicht aufmachen.
Wenn ich die Katzenvideos aufmache, dann empfiehlt mir Google nur noch Katzenvideos.
Ab und zu was anderes wäre auch nicht verkehrt.
Guck, was haben wir?
Katzenvideos und Weep-Videos, Alter.
Chico hätte sich das Ding einmal angeguckt, hätte vielleicht draufgekriegt.
Und wäre dann weggegangen.
Slack AI could be tricked.
Ja, Slack feels Batman.
So, dann gucken wir uns nochmal an.
Was bringt 6 Gigahertz?
Das bringt erst einmal wahrscheinlich gar nicht viel, bis du Geräte hast, die das unterstützen, oder?
Wie sieht es denn aus, wenn man sich ein ganz, ganz neues iPhone, sagen wir mal, kauft?
Oder ein neues Google Pixel 9?
Oder wo sind die jetzt?
Das, was jetzt irgendwie 1800 Euro kostet für ein fucking Smartphone.
Und da stürzen die schon 6 Gigahertz?
Was wurde eigentlich aus der K...
Ja, hier, guck mal.
Die wurde...
Das Geld kam zusammen.
Und Sammy wurde mittlerweile schon operiert.
Und Sammy geht es jetzt wieder gut.
Also, nach der OP geht es ihm wieder gut.
Das Bein ist noch nicht geheilt.
Guck, aber wurde alles operiert.
Der Fuß heilt von alleine.
Und Sammy ist wieder den Umständen entsprechend fit nach der Operation.
Letzte Woche war es so, dass er sich wieder gut gehalten hat.
Letzte Woche, Mittwoch wurde Sammy operiert.
Habe ich vorhin schon gezeigt.
Aber finde ich nice, dass ihr fragt.
Das ist nicht meine Meinung.
Meine Katze müsste nicht...
Bräuchte keine Spenden fürs Tierheim, um operiert zu werden.
Außerdem wäre meine Katze auch höchstwahrscheinlich nicht vom Auto angefahren worden.
Also, ich vermute mal, dass er vom Auto angefahren wurde.
Das Geld ist zusammengekommen.
Ist sogar relativ schnell zusammengekommen.
Sogar letzte Woche noch.
Oder diese Woche noch.
Vor Mittwoch.
Werden die nicht schnell aufgeben?
Nee.
Pixel-Phones haben von Android-Geräten eines der längsten Support-Zeiträume.
Die sind da eigentlich mit am besten.
Kann sein.
Wir kennen uns flüchtig von ganz, ganz früher.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es gibt Custom-Roms für Pixel.
Wisst ihr, was ich gerne hätte?
Ich hätte gerne ein...
Alter, ich muss mal kurz was trinken.
Ich hätte gerne ein Custom-Rom
für mein altes...
NVIDIA-Tablet.
Das ist nämlich so ein richtig schönes,
kleines,
handliches,
weiß ich nicht,
6-Zoll-Tablet.
So ein richtig kleines Furztablet ist das.
Das passt aber genau bei mir
neben dem Klo, also neben dem Badeingang
an die Wand.
Das ist nur so eine ganz kurze,
kleine Ecke an der Wand.
Und genau da passt das Tablet hin.
Leider,
kann ich das Tablet nicht verwenden,
weil es dafür kein aktuelles Rom gibt.
Das ist uralt.
Aber ich würde da gar nichts großartig
drauf anzeigen, außer halt einen Browser aufmachen.
Und ich habe noch kein...
Das ist ein ganz, ganz...
Das ist ein Tegra...
Tegra-Node-Tablet.
So ein ganz kleines Furztablet.
Ja, NVIDIA hat mal das Shield-Tablet
gemacht und davor hatten sie das
Tegra-Node-7. Das war auch ein NVIDIA-Tablet.
Das war so ein ganz kleines,
ja, und das ist sehr nice.
So ein ganz kleines Furztablet ist das.
Das ist richtig geil.
Und das ist das einzige Tablet, was ich habe,
was dorthin passt an die Wand, neben dem Bad.
Und ich hätte dort gern mein Home Assistant Dashboard.
Wenn ich aufs Klo gehe, dass ich irgendwas tippen kann drauf.
Aber ich finde kein aktuelles Rom für.
Und die ROMs, die es dafür gibt, sind so alt,
da hast du so übelst outdated, dass du nicht mehr so viel Zeit hast.
Aber ich finde kein aktuelles ROM für. Und die ROMs, die es dafür gibt, sind so alt,
Da hast du so übelst outdated, dass du nicht mehr so viel Zeit hast.
Da funktioniert das alles nicht mehr drauf.
Ja, kannst du vergessen auf dem Ding.
Das ist ein Android, boah, keine Ahnung.
Ur-Ur-Uralt.
Da hätte ich gerne ein halbwegs aktuelles Android-ROM.
Und ja, NVIDIA hat Tablets gemacht.
Die haben das Shield-Tablet gemacht.
Das Shield-Tablet war eines der Tablets,
die Akku-Probleme hatten und abfackeln konnten.
Wo du dir kostenlos ein Austauschgerät bestellen konntest.
Also, nein, sollte das Mindeste sein,
dass es kostenlos ist, wenn es schon
deine Bude abfackeln kann.
Fire-Tablets. Ja, aber es gibt
kein so kleines Fire-Tablet, was da hinpasst.
Ja, aber das ist immer so.
Das ist das einzige, was ich habe.
Großartig teures
kaufen will ich jetzt auch nicht.
Das ist so nice to have.
Ja, jetzt aber mal
zur eigentlichen Thematik zurück.
Haben denn die neuesten Pixel und neuesten
iPhones überhaupt schon
6 GHz WLAN am Start?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Tegra Note 7
überhaupt 7 Zoll ist.
Vom Namen her wäre das zu vermuten.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt
ein 6 GHz Access Point
hätte, würde das überhaupt
was bringen?
Also mit den, weil es die
neuesten Geräte schon haben, oder nicht?
Hat denn Pixel, Pixel 9
6 GHz
hat es 6 GHz WLAN?
Ah ja, hat es anscheinend.
Tech-Spec
hier. Hat es.
Okay. Na dann.
Also
bei mir ist, ich bin
da nicht so fortschrittlich. Ich habe
ein iPhone, was ist das?
14 oder so hier und
von der Firma ein 12er ist das glaube ich.
Und meine
Access Points sind auch nur
2,4 und 5 GHz.
Und ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich mir angucke,
was ein Satz neuer
Access Points kosten würde
von dem Hersteller,
dann bleibe ich erstmal eine Weile noch
auf meinem
auf meinen älteren Access Points.
Ich meine, ich habe hier
ich habe diese Access Points hier
zwei Stück, wobei
im Keller habe ich einen 510, hier oben
habe ich einen 710
und die sind schon ein paar Jahre alt.
Aber die sind wirklich
sehr nice, auch was die Features angeht.
Brauchen auch keinen extra Controller und sonst was.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn man sich
einen neuen kauft,
dann kostet
das einfach, ich muss mal gucken, ob das überhaupt
die neuesten sind, ja eher 770
haben wir sogar schon.
Dann sind die etwas
teurer.
Oh, das ist richtig günstig.
Leute, hier gibt es ja mal einen
zwischendurch für nur
1417 Euro.
Das ist ja fast geschenkt, Mann.
OCTO24.
Das ist so teuer und die können euch
mal ein Bild reinmachen.
Alternativ können wir auch bei
ITK Admin.
Guck.
2,456 Gigahertz.
1484 Euro.
Yeah.
Richtiger Schnapper, gell.
Die sind aber wirklich nice, die Access Points.
Muss ich sagen, sind die besten Access Points,
die ich je hatte.
Also, die 710er.
Ich habe keine 1500 Euro
dafür ausgegeben.
Die besten Access Points, die ich je hatte.
Auch mit
das beste Interface.
Warum sind die so teuer?
Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Die haben viele coole Features
und die haben auch ein paar Sachen gehabt,
lange bevor das andere Hersteller hatten.
Und teilweise auch immer noch
besser als das andere Hersteller haben.
Aber...
Moment, Zigbee?
Die Dinger können mittlerweile
auch Bluetooth und Zigbee?
Ja, das ist nice.
Das finde ich cool.
Wer kauft die denn, wenn die so
teuer sind?
Wenn du zum Beispiel ein zuverlässiges
WLAN auf deinem Firmengelände brauchst,
kaufst du dir die.
Ich weiß nicht, wie beliebt die in Deutschland
sind, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, in den USA sind die enorm beliebt,
der Hersteller.
In Deutschland weiß ich es nicht.
Aber ich bin ja auch kein hauptsächlich
hauptberuflicher Netzwerker, der irgendwie
WLANs irgendwo aufbaut.
Weiß ich nicht, wie beliebt die sind.
Aber sie sind von den WLAN-Herstellern
auch.
Hauptsächlich im...
Ubiquiti ist günstiger, ja.
Aber Ubiquiti ist auch nerviger.
Mittlerweile hat, immerhin,
haben sie es geschafft,
bei den neuen Unifi Access Points
ein Feature einzubauen,
was die hier schon seit 10 Jahren
können, was ich die ganze Zeit
haben wollte. Eines der Gründe war, warum
ich mir die überhaupt gekauft habe.
Wie gesagt, ich habe nicht die teuren,
ich habe die R710 noch.
Ab und zu mal relativ günstig.
Also, ich hatte ja auch
Unifi Access Points.
Einer der Gründe...
Also, es gab mehrere Gründe, warum ich
Unifi rausgeschmissen habe.
Nehmen wir mal den Haupt...
Lassen wir mal alles außen drum herum.
Nehmen wir mal den Hauptgrund.
Was mich genervt hat bei Unifi ist,
dass die keine
WLAN-Passwörter für einzelne Geräte
unterstützen.
Also so, dass du jedem Gerät ein einzelnes
WLAN-Passwort geben kannst.
Könnten sie das, aber auch erst seit einem
dreiviertel Jahr oder so. Andere Hersteller
können das seit sieben, acht, neun Jahren
oder so schon.
Und das wollte
Unifi oder Ubiquiti
wollte das irgendwie einfach ganz lange
nicht einbauen. Und ich finde, das ist
gerade, wenn man viele IoT-Geräte hat,
ein sehr, sehr nützliches Feature.
Oder generell, wenn man viele WLAN-Geräte
hat, ein sehr nützliches Feature.
Zum Beispiel...
Ach ja, und ich meine übrigens nicht
WPA Enterprise, sondern ich meine
ein ganz normales, billiges
WPA2, nicht Enterprise,
einzelne
WLAN-Passwörter pro Gerät.
Also kein
WLAN-Passwort
für alle Geräte, das gleiche Passwort
im gleichen WLAN, sondern
für das gleiche WLAN
ein Passwort für jedes Gerät.
Das können viele Hersteller schon seit Jahren.
Ubiquiti kann das erst
seit einem dreiviertel Jahr oder einem Jahr,
wenn es hochkommt. Das haben die erst in einem
der meisten Firmwaren eingebaut.
Und das ist etwas, was mir schon immer gestunken hat,
plus die anderen Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gegangen sind,
damals bei Ubiquiti oder bei
Unifi, warum ich gesagt habe,
ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock mehr auf Unifi.
Und dann habe ich mich mal umgeguckt und habe festgestellt,
dass diese Ruckus
Access Points oder Ruckus Access Points
sehr nice sind von Features
her und auch keinen
extra Controller brauchen,
weil die untereinander quasi so ein
P2P-Netz aufbauen und
jeder der Access Points, der genug Kapazitäten hat,
macht den Controller gleich mit.
Also brauchst du keinen Raspberry Pi mehr mit einem
Unifi Controller oder sowas, sondern das läuft halt
einfach auf dem Access Point mit.
Das ist was ich sehr nice finde.
Und jetzt mal als Beispiel, wenn man sich fragt,
warum braucht man das? Dieses Feature nennt sich übrigens
auch bei
Unifi glaube ich,
DPSK nennt sich das.
Private Pre-Shared, also quasi ein WLAN
Passwort, dass du WLAN Passwörter
pro Gerät vergeben kannst.
Ja, es gab ein paar Hacks für
Unifi. So, und jetzt mal als Beispiel,
wofür das sinnvoll ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt einen Drucker,
mal, Who's Source?
So.
Letztens erst,
letztens erst, das
ähm,
wieder so eine Situation gehabt.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt einen WLAN, ihr habt
einen Multifunktions-WLAN Drucker,
Drucker, der im WLAN ist.
Können das die IoT-Geräte? Ja, das ist ja das Gute
daran, das Gerät muss es
nicht unterstützen.
Das Gerät ist das ganz normales
WLAN, WPA2-WLAN.
Das ist nicht ein extra
Protokoll, wie WPA Enterprise,
sondern das ist
transparent für das Endgerät.
Das ist ja das Gute daran.
Du kannst quasi das Gerät in
das WLAN einbinden, ganz normal,
ohne dass das Gerät was davon weiß, aber
dein Access Point checkt das, dass
es ein extra Passwort für dieses Gerät gibt.
Na, zumindest,
Drucker, ihr habt ein Multifunktionsgerät Drucker.
Ich habe letztens einen alten
Epson-Drucker weggeschmissen.
Der stand bei mir
jetzt ein paar Jahre rum,
hier unter der Treppe, zum
wegschmeißen. Ich habe mir vor einer Weile
so einen Tintenstrahl,
das war ein Tintenstrahl-Epson-Drucker,
ich habe mir vor einer Weile von Brother so einen
Multifunktions-Laserdrucker gekauft,
mit dem ich auch sehr happy bin, der einfach auch
funktioniert. Ich druck nicht viel im Jahr, aber
jedes Mal, wenn ich was drucken wollte mit meinem
Tintenstrahl-Drucker, ging es nicht gescheit.
Irgendwann habe ich mal
übelst feste draufgeschlagen
und
dann,
ja, ich war in der Hand auch gedruckt,
aber das Papier kam nicht mehr gerade
raus, das war unten, egal.
Ja, und
so, also, ich habe
das Multifunktions-Ding
und habe das
unter die Treppe gestellt
und wollte es wegschmeißen. So, und jetzt ist halt das Ding,
wenn ihr euer
Multifunktions-Drucker wegschmeißt,
ja, ihr habt das Stromkabel nicht mehr, vielleicht
geht das Display nicht mehr oder whatever,
dann schmeißt ihr den Drucker
weg, irgendjemand anderes,
es geht jetzt nur darum, dass es theoretisch möglich
ist, ich will nicht sagen, wie wahrscheinlich das
ist, ja, ihr schmeißt den Drucker
weg, irgendjemand macht eure
Mülltonne auf oder
nimmt sich das Ding vom Wertstoffhof
mit oder was auch immer,
macht das Ding an und liest euer
WLAN-Passwort aus.
Und hat euer WLAN-Passwort.
Und kommt in euer WLAN rein.
Mit einem alten Gerät, was ihr
weggeschmissen habt.
Wenn ihr jetzt WLAN-Passwörter
habt, pro Gerät,
dann geht ihr in euren Access Point,
löscht das Gerät
und schmeißt das Gerät weg.
Ihr müsst es nicht factory resetten,
ihr müsst es nicht zerstören, ihr schmeißt
es einfach weg. Das ist halt
nice.
Obwohl, gemerkt, das Gerät muss kein
Enterprise, WPA oder sonst was
unterstützen, sondern ganz
normales WPA2.
Ohne Sperenzien. Das heißt, es geht
mit jeder IoT-Glühbirne
oder mit jeder IoT-
WLAN-Steckdose.
Die alle kein WPA Enterprise können.
Das war
eines der Features, die ich schon lange haben wollte,
gerade weil ich viele kleine IoT-Geräte und
Microcontroller habe und die einfach
gefahrlos wegschmeißen können möchte.
Das ist ein Feature, das ich lange hatte
und UniFi konnte das nicht.
Mittlerweile kann es das, aber ich habe
es seit ein paar Jahren schon rausgeschmissen.
Und die Ruckus Access Points können das
seit Jahren schon.
Und haben auch sonst ganz coole Features.
Und sind quasi
mit der Unleashed-Firmware sind die auch
Controllerless.
In dem Sinne, weil einer der Access Points
den Controller-Part übernimmt.
Finde ich nice. Nichtsdestotrotz
1500 Euro für
einen Access Point, jetzt für einen neuen,
würde ich jetzt auch nicht einfach mal so
just for fun ausgeben.
Dann warte ich lieber, bis es auf eBay
die
letzte Generation
irgendwie gibt.
Wobei, die haben sich ja irgendwo festgeklebt.
Die gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht auf eBay.
Ob es die vorvorvorletzte
Access Point Generation
irgendwo auf eBay gibt.
Guck mal, die gibt es schon.
Da gibt es schon eine R720.
Da wird schon ein bisschen billiger.
Ich glaube R730 gab es nie.
Doch, gab es auch. Guck mal hier.
Ach übrigens,
da muss man gucken,
diese
Geräte sind eigentlich nur
für
Caconaland gedacht.
Also du kannst das eigentlich nur
gescheit in den USA verwenden, wenn da
US drin steht. Aber glücklicherweise
gibt es
die Möglichkeit, die
Firmware
zu resetten.
Also es sind die gleichen
Geräte, nur die Firmware unterscheidet sich.
Und
es gibt einen Trick,
gibt es auch auf GitHub.
Ja, finde ich nicht.
Aber da gibt es eine Anleitung zu, wie man
eine alte Firmware flasht,
dann quasi dort
eine Rootshell bekommt auf der alten Firmware.
Und
die WLAN-Config resetet
und dann die neue Firmware flasht.
Und dann kannst du ein US-Gerät
ohne Probleme als EU-Gerät verwenden.
Das frunzt.
Das heißt, man kann
dann auch die etwas günstige US-Variante
benutzen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das mit den R730 noch geht.
Ja, aber da kommen wir
schon mal in einen Bereich, wo ich sagen würde,
ja, da kann man sich vielleicht
mal überlegen, sowas zu kaufen hier.
Ah, das ist schon
ein AX-Access Point.
Ja, das würde ich mir
vielleicht überlegen. Wobei das halt so ein Ding ist,
da kommt ja noch Versand dabei.
78 Dollar
Versand. Keckweh.
Ja, da muss man mal gucken, was man mal...
Artikel Standort
Europa oder so suchen.
Oh, da gibt es sogar 550.
Also, ich kaufe mir
lieber was von der älteren Generation.
Ja, ich wollte mal auf
meinen alten
UniFi AX-Access Point
wollte ich OpenWrt drauf machen und
gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Beziehungsweise...
Huch.
Meine Fernbedienung ist...
Die Batterie leer, wie sie aussieht.
Gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Meine Fernbedienung
für die Klimaanlage hat sich gerade rebooted.
Bin ich ganz sicher,
warum die das gemacht hat.
Wusste gar nicht, dass sie sich
rebooten kann, ehrlich gesagt.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade sagen?
Also, ich wollte
es tatsächlich mal ausprobieren, ob ich
auf meinen alten UniFi AX-Access Point
OpenWrt drauf bekomme
und was man mit OpenWrt
auf so einem UniFi AX-Access Point machen kann.
Es ist ja dann kein UniFi AX-Access Point mehr.
Es ist zwar noch so ein blauer,
weiß-blauer AX-Access Point,
wo UniFi draufsteht, aber hat mit UniFi
da nichts mehr zu tun.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren, was damit
mittlerweile auch an Features alles möglich ist.
Früher war OpenWrt eines der besten
Sachen, die man machen konnte.
Mal schauen.
Weil an sich sind die UniFi AX-Access Points
ja von der Hardware ganz brauchbar.
Ist jetzt nicht irgendwie super
high-end oder so, aber schon
okay.
Und wenn man die Standalone als OpenWrt
AX-Access Point betreiben kann, sind die vielleicht
auch ganz nice, ja. Mal ausprobieren.
Ja, das wollte ich tatsächlich machen.
So, dann gucken wir uns doch jetzt mal an,
was denn die neue Fritzbox
so kann.
Warum ist das eigentlich eine 5.690?
Sind wir bei der Fritzbox nicht schon
bei 6.000 eigentlich?
Ah, 6.000 sind die Repeater.
Ja gut, das ist ja normal.
Aber das ist in der heutigen Zeit
gar nicht mehr so extrem.
Also, es gibt natürlich viele WLANs,
aber die meisten AX-Access Points
haben ja so in den letzten Jahren über
die Möglichkeit... Ey, meine Fernbedienung
hat sich schon wieder rebooted. What the
fuck, Alter?
Was ist das? Was ist da los?
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Ne, die Batterie ist nicht leer. Die habe ich erst vor
einer Woche oder so getauscht.
Wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Das...
Keine Ahnung.
Was hat er denn gesagt?
Bin ich mit meinem WLAN infiliert?
Achso, ja. Die meisten AX-Access Points,
die können ja mittlerweile scannen,
was es für WLANs in der Umgebung gibt
und dementsprechend sich auf
einen Kanal legen, der noch nicht
so benutzt ist. Also, das ist gar nicht so
schlimm mehr.
Aber es gibt halt
auch immer mehr WLANs, ja.
... und stören meine Übertragung.
Finde ich natürlich doof. Schließlich sind
meine Daten am wichtigsten.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Natürlich will ich, dass meine Daten flutschen.
Und das Ding ist, dass es dafür ja gerade...
Was lupicht das WLAN vom Nachbarn?
... also einen Frequenzbereich,
der erst seit einiger Zeit...
Aber, by the way, je höher
die Frequenz, umso schlechter
geht das durch Wände.
Das sollte man immer im Hinterkopf behalten.
Also, potenziell geht
2,4 Gigahertz deutlich besser
bis, keine Ahnung,
vom ersten Stock bis in den Keller
wie 5 oder 6 Gigahertz.
... WLAN benutzt werden darf.
Und seit ich das erste Mal davon gehört habe, denke ich,
das will ich. Ein Frequenzbereich,
der zumindest jetzt in der Anfangsphase
nur von uns Early Adopters
benutzt wird. Ja, also freie
Datenbahn für freie Nerds.
Ja, und nun gibt es
den ersten Router mit
eingebautem Modem, der 6 Gigahertz
unterstützt. Und zwar...
Fritzbox 5690 Pro
von AVM.
3 und 4 Gigahertz sind für andere Sachen geblockt.
Ja, es kann nicht jedes Frequenzband für alles
verwendet werden.
Die habe ich mir zu Hause installiert und guck mir das
jetzt mal genau an, was das jetzt
konkret bringt mit diesem neuen Frequenzbereich
und natürlich vor allem, ob das in der Praxis
jetzt wirklich so einen Unterschied macht.
Ja gut, und WiFi 7 hat das
Ding natürlich auch im Gepäck. Und ganz ehrlich,
und das ist jetzt kein Bait, das...
Also 5G...
Das ist ja mit der...
Benamung halt ein bisschen
weirdchamp. 5G
liegt irgendwo zwischen 3
und 4,5 Gigahertz oder
so in dem Dreh. Fragt mich nicht
genau. Ja, also Mobilfunk
5G, fünfte Generation
Mobilfunk liegt irgendwie
zwischen 3 und 4,5 Gigahertz.
Ergebnis hat mich überrascht.
Bleibt dran.
Hallo? Hallo? Hallo?
Kann mich ein Deutscher hören?
Gibt's den überhaupt noch?
Ja, aber egal wie schnell
euer WLAN ist, NordVPN
könnte für euch sehr praktisch sein.
Die sponsern unser Video.
Mit NordVPN könnt ihr euch nämlich ganz einfach
in beliebige Länder tunneln. Und wenn man
dann auf irgendeine Website geht, denkt die,
man ist eben in diesem anderen Land.
Damit kann man zum Beispiel Sachen bestellen,
die hierzulande nicht erhältlich sind,
andere Filme und Serien zum Beispiel auf Netflix
gucken. Man kann aber auch, wie schon gesagt,
Geld sparen. Weil
bei sowas wie Flügen, Mietwagen und Hotels
sind ja, je nach Land,
in dem die Buchung stattfindet, die Preise
unterschiedlich. Das lohnt sich,
das mal auszuprobieren. Und das könnt ihr
bei NordVPN mit 30 Tagen
Geld zurückgaben.
NordVPN wollte bei mir keine
Werbung machen. Die wollten erst Werbung
machen, dann haben sie gesagt, ich soll ein
Video löschen, wo ich mich mal ein bisschen
negativ über VPNs geäußert hab.
Dann hab ich ihnen gesagt, ich will das nicht
löschen und dann wollten sie nicht mehr.
Dann hab ich mir gedacht, ja, Pech gehabt.
Und wenn ihr über nordvpn.com
bestellt, bekommt ihr exklusiv
vier Monate extra
aufs Zwei-Jahres-Abo obendrauf.
Der Link ist auch hier unten
in der Beschreibung.
Ja, ich kann mich da noch
genau dran erinnern. Anfang
2021 hab ich den Video-Podcast
CT-Uplink moderiert.
Empfehlung übrigens.
Bis nächste Video, keck wait.
Jeden Freitag ein neues Video hier auf YouTube.
Und da ging es um die Öffnung
des neuen dritten Frequenz-Spektrums
für WLAN, das als
6 Gigahertz bezeichnet wird.
Bislang gab es nur zwei Frequenz-Bereiche
für WLAN, nämlich 2,4
und 5 Gigahertz. Ja, und damals
hatte ich mir auf jeden Fall fest vorgenommen,
oh, megageil, will ich unbedingt
haben, sobald es das gibt.
Das Problem war nur, dass in den Jahren
danach halt kein einziger Router
mit einem eingebauten Modem rauskam,
der die...
Wie sieht's halt mit Endgeräten aus?
Da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher,
ob das so viele schon können.
...neuen sogenannten WiFi-6E-Standard unterstützt.
Also es gab zwar Router mit der Technik,
aber da hätte ich dann noch ein separates Modem
an...
Ich bin immer wieder fasziniert,
wie abgedreht
Routers mittlerweile aussehen können.
Die sehen ja teilweise
wirklich so Stealth-Bomber-mäßig aus.
Oder wie eine Krabbe
fast schon.
...schließen müssen. Und ja, das
kostet halt extra Energie und das will ich
nicht. Man kann nämlich grob sagen,
so ein separates Modem, egal ob
Kabel, DSL oder Glasfaser, saugt
so zwischen 5 bis 8 Watt.
Das stimmt.
Ja, gut, wenn's danach geht, das ist schon
richtig, ja. Ich bin eigentlich
auch blöd, ne? Ich hätte schon längst
das mal umstellen sollen.
Ich hab ja aktuell noch eine olle Fritzbox,
die macht bei mir DECT-Basisstation.
Ja, ich hab noch zwei
schnurlose DECT-Telefone.
Und VoIP und
so Zeug macht die.
Und dann hab ich noch als
Kabel-Modem
das Ding von Unity Media. Ich hätte
auch schon längst mal eine ordentliche Fritzbox
anschließen sollen, die Kabel-Modem
und das Ganze in einem ist. Aber da war ich bisher zu faul
dafür. Ja, und
ganz ehrlich, dann sind's halt
8 Watt mehr, die mein
Serverraum braucht. So what?
Mal ne Fra... Okay, Moment.
Chatge... Wat?
Moin, mal eine Frage. Ich mach gerade
Ausbildung zum Feezy. Und bei
uns dreht der Server ab und zu mal
richtig auf für ein paar Sekunden und
danach wieder runter. Aber man sieht nichts bei der
CPU-Addisbelastung. Hättest du da eine Idee?
Und wir sind momentan leider...
Der rebootet nicht zufällig
der Server, oder? Der kackt nicht ab und
rebootet. Das merkst du ja,
wenn da drauf eingeloggt bist, ob der gerade weg ist.
Beim Rebooten drehen die alle mal hoch.
Ist da Linux
oder Windows drauf?
Mit Linux hätte ich jetzt ne Idee.
Und mal zumindest
servertechnisch nachgucken kann.
Unter Windows kein Plan. Ansonsten musst
du ins ILO
oder ins RSA oder wie auch immer das
Management Interface von dem Ding heißt
und gucken, ob du irgendwelche
Temperaturschwellen
anpassen kannst.
Aber die meisten Server
für den Rechenzentrumsbetrieb
Ja, ich würd mit LMSensors
einfach mal gucken, was er erkennt.
Ob man da irgendwas auslesen kann.
Ansonsten wirst du nicht viel...
Kannst wahrscheinlich nicht viel machen, außer in das
Management Interface zu gehen.
Und dort
hoffen, dass es ein paar Temperaturschwellen gibt,
die du anpassen kannst. Das Ding ist halt, die meisten
Server, die fürs Rechenzentrum
gedacht sind,
die sind nicht wirklich auf
leisen
Betrieb ausgelegt.
Also mein
Lieblings
Lüfter
Gebläse ist ja immer noch
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das hier sieht.
Das ist immer noch
mein Lieblings
Gebläse.
Hört euch das mal an.
Das ist ein Plate Center. Das ist quasi ein
Plate Center, in der du zwölf
Fünfzehn?
Ich glaub zwölf, gell?
Zwölf kleine Rechner reinschieben kannst.
Let's do that.
Pass mal auf jetzt.
Also es gibt ja, muss ich das mal erzählen.
Bevor ich jetzt hier das anmache.
Ich will
ja seit Jahren, seit Jahren
Also
ich werd das wahrscheinlich nie machen
können, weil diese Plate Center in der Form
gibt es ja so gar nicht mehr.
Mir schwebt seit Jahren schon
vor, ich möchte
so einen Plate Center mal
auf leichtgängige Rollen
stellen und gucken
wie schnell das fahren
kann.
Wenn du es volle Pulle pusten lässt.
So keine Ahnung
ein Plate Center auf zwei Inline Skates
geschnallt und dann
volle Pulle und einfach mal fahren lassen.
Das red mir seit Jahren schon vor,
dass ich einfach mal, das würde ich echt gerne mal machen.
Gucken wie schnell das wird.
Ja, jetzt hört euch das mal an. Das ist echt nicht normal, das Teil, wenn das
voll hochdreht.
Let's do that.
So, plug it in.
And
Of course this seems fairly silent.
Now I don't know if you can hear me,
but this is pretty much running at full speed.
Also, ich lasse
es jetzt mal.
You can probably feel the hair.
Das ist wirklich wie eine Flugzeugturbine, das denk ich
Alter.
Ja, und
wisst ihr?
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr hockt im rechten Zentrum
dahinter.
Ihr hockt so wie der im rechten Zentrum dahinter
und das Ding bläst volle Pulle.
So, und der Rechner ist
ungefähr so auf
Schienbeinhöhe, wo ihr was bauen müsst.
Das heißt, ihr sitzt in der Hocke
vor diesem Ding. Ihr müsst euch, ohne Scheiß,
ihr müsst euch aktiv
in der Hocke aktiv
vorwärts lehnen,
dass ihr nicht nach hinten umgeblasen
werdet. So viel bläst das.
Aber diese Art
von Platesender gibt es nicht mehr. Also Platesender
gibt es noch, aber diese Art und
Bauart, ich weiß nicht, wie die aktuellen von IBM aussehen,
gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich muss sagen, das ist
und bleibt wahrscheinlich für immer
meine Lieblingsserver-Hardware.
Nichts, was ich mir jemals daheim
hinstellen würde, selbst wenn ich für
150 Euro ein bestücktes,
altes Platesender bei Ebay bekommen würde.
Ihr hört ja, wie laut das ist,
wie viel Strom das braucht. Im Leben nicht.
Fiber Channel Anschluss und alles mögliche.
Das wird aber trotzdem immer meine
Lieblingsserver-Hardware bleiben.
Ich fand die Dinge einfach mega nice.
Die alten Platesender.
Und wer sich jetzt denkt,
mit dem Platesender ist das
Ganze getan,
die Rechner, die man da vorne reinsteckt,
also das Ganze sieht ja,
so sieht das von vorne aus, genau.
Guck mal, so sieht das von vorne aus.
Das sind quasi die einzelnen Plates, die du reinsteckst.
Das sind quasi einzelne,
ne, das sind leere Slots und das ist quasi ein komplett
einzelner Computer.
Ja, das hier. Das ist ein vollwertiger
Computer, den du reinsteckst. Den kannst du auch
einzeln anschalten, der hat auch eine eigene Netzwerkkarte,
einen eigenen Fiber Channel Anschluss,
du kannst dein eigenes Betriebssystem drauflegen,
vollständiger eigener Computer hier.
Und die Plates, die fettesten, die wir damals hatten,
waren HS23 Plates
mit bis
zu 2 Terabyte
RAM gab's die damals.
Ihr müsst euch überlegen, das ist
länger als 7 Jahre her.
Und damals waren 2 Terabyte
RAM, ich mein, 2 Terabyte RAM ist heute noch
viel, ja, aber damals
waren 2 Terabyte RAM komplett
ja,
jenseits von all dem, was man sich so
vorstellen konnte.
Und du hättest dafür locker
ein Auto kaufen können für so ein Plate Center.
Also nicht für ein Plate Center,
für ein Plate.
Für so ein vollbestücktes Plate hättest du locker
ein Auto kaufen können.
Und ich weiß noch, als den Felix und mich damals
mit solchen Dingern quer durch Frankfurt geschickt haben
in der Straßenbahn,
das Gute
daran ist, echt nicht?
Moment.
Wir hatten
2 Terabyte Kisten damals.
Standardmäßig waren glaube ich
96 Gigabyte.
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Wir hatten 2 Terabyte,
2 Terabyte RAM Kisten.
Bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher, dass das
auch Plates waren. Vielleicht waren's auch keine
HS23 Plates, whatever.
Das ist, keine Ahnung, 12 Jahre her.
Oder so. Zumindest,
die haben uns damals durch Frankfurt geschickt
mit den Dingern.
Und, ähm...
Ja gut, die Azubis wurden damals durch Frankfurt
hättet. Was denn sonst? Das Gute
ist, dass niemand
in Frankfurt wusste, dass wir da
gerade mit, keine Ahnung,
150.000 Euro durch Frankfurt gelaufen
sind.
Unterm Arm.
Das ist zu advanced für die.
Hat uns keiner überfallen
und ausgeraubt.
Wenn du mit 150.000 Euro so
öffentlich in Frankfurt rumlaufen würdest, hättest du
wahrscheinlich ein Problem. Wenn du mit 150.000
Euro in Hardware rumläufst, ist es
kein Ding.
Wir mussten auch damals mit so nem
ollen Bollerwagen,
ne, nicht mal nem Bollerwagen, sondern so nem flachen Wagen,
mussten wir
Loadbalancer Appliance
in Frankfurt rumfahren.
Die auch 20.000 Euro
pro Stück gekostet haben.
Kennt ihr...
Wie heißen denn hier...
Wie heißen denn diese
kleinen... Ja!
Sowas in...
Sowas, so'n Ding hier. Genau so'n Ding.
So'n Ding war das.
Aber, aber nicht mit
aufgepumpten Rädern, sondern
mit diesen, so'n Teil hier, mit so
harten Gummirädern war. Das war so'n Klappding
mit harten Gummirädern.
Und da mussten wir
glaub 5 oder 6 Stück
haben da drauf gepasst.
20.000 Euro pro Stück
Loadbalancer Appliance mussten wir
in Frankfurt rumfahren und
in Frankfurt sind die Gehwege nicht
unbedingt immer gerade.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie das ist,
wenn man
Metallgehäuse auf
Metallgehäuse legt
und dann so
20% Neigung oder, na 20%
Neigung ist ein bisschen krasser, so'n paar
Prozent Neigung hat, dann muss
immer auf der Seite, wo die Neigung vom
Weg ist, einer laufen, dass die Sachen nicht runter
fallen.
Ja, das waren, das waren schon echt ganz abenteuerliche
Geschichten damals. Vor allem, dass
sie irgendwie die
die Azubis, die so ultra
teuren Dinger, in nem nicht
noch nicht mal luftgepolsterten Wagen
quer durch Frankfurt haben fahren lassen.
Ja, ja, ja, 150.000
Euro Hardware, aber die Azubis müssen
nicht zu Fuß durch Frankfurt, ah ja, so ist es.
Das ist heute bestimmt immer noch nicht
anders. Ähm, aber mal hier,
du bist ja ein Kenner,
du Schlitzer, welche Kiste könnten
das gewesen sein, so zu dieser damaligen
Zeit mit 2TB?
Es war auf jeden Fall ne IBM-Kiste
und ich bilde mir ein, es war ein
Plate von IBM.
Es war, es waren 2TB
Plates. Relativ
sicher eigentlich. Das war
auch zu Zeiten, wo wir damals
äh, GPU
ausprobiert haben, in keinen
ging 2TB rein,
dann war's vielleicht kein Plate.
Ja, aber vielleicht war's ja kein
HS23, vielleicht war's ja ein anderes.
Ich, ich bin mir, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass
das 64GB Module
waren damals.
Uber gab es damals nicht, keck weh
alter, Uber!
Da hat damals
keiner dran gedacht, das gab's nicht.
Das war 2009?
Oder so?
Ja, stimmt. Ne, dann kann es das nicht
gewesen sein, da kommst du nicht auf 2TB.
Ich glaub 64GB Module gingen da auch nicht drinne.
Da muss es irgendwas anderes gewesen
sein.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was ist das?
Turbolüfter aus HP Platesender vs.
Karotte.
Ne, das, ich mein nicht auf dem Bild, auf dem Bild sind ja noch
irgendwelche Sunkisten. Das Bild ist einfach
das erste Beste, was ich gefunden hab auf, auf
Youtube. Was ist das?
Häckselt der jetzt die Karotte
da drin oder was?
Was ein Schwachsinn, man!
Okay, ich bin nicht der Einzige, der auf blöde Ideen
bei den Platesenderlüftern gekommen ist.
Da fragt man sich einfach nur
but why? Aber so richtig
so richtig gut
so richtig gut schneiden
tut das nicht, gell?
Warum hieß das Plate?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Warum das Plate hieß. Also mir ist klar,
warum es Platesender hieß,
weil man in das Platesender mehrere Plates
gesteckt hat.
Vielleicht so wie Messer in ein Messerblock
oder so.
Weiß ich, warum das, warum die,
warum das, warum man die Serverplates
genannt hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Warum gleich darum.
Das wird aber für immer, ohne Mist
wird das meine Lieblings-Hardware bleiben.
Ich fand die Dinger,
gerade die, ich fand die Dinger einfach
geil. Ich fand die Dinger einfach
nice.
DVD-Laufwerk, das Floppy.
Ja.
HS20.
Das waren so die ersten,
die ich davon gesehen hab damals.
Das war schon nice, der Hardware.
Ja, hier vorne
konntest du übrigens Monitor
Output und
CD-Output umschalten.
Also, wenn du, mal angenommen, du siehst, ihr seht ja
hier oben hast du nur ein CD-Laufwerk
und hinten hast du auch nur ein
Monitor-Output, wobei hatten die nicht vorne noch ein
VGA? Und
du musstest dann hier oben mit den Knöpfen
konntest du umschalten, welches der
Plates denn das CD-Laufwerk,
das DVD-Laufwerk benutzt.
Das war schon sehr nice.
Was ist, was ist ein DZ?
Ok, gucken wir uns mal das, das
Router, wie, ach im
Discord. Bin hier nicht
eingeloggt im Discord.
Mal gucken. Naja, ich kann mir das
grad nicht angucken. Ich bin nicht eingeloggt im
Discord. Ne, hör ich nicht.
Keine, keine Coding.
Ich bin Podcasts allgemein
super langweilig. Gibt nix, was ich
mir da anhöre.
Ich guck jetzt mal das Video fertig.
Pro Kilowattstunde kosten 8 Watt schon
über 20 Euro im Jahr. Ja, also
8 Watt, das ist fast so viel wie ein ganzer
WLAN-Router. Nämlich zum Vergleich
die Fritzbox 5690
Pro, die ich hier im Video teste,
die genehmigt sich mit ausgeschaltetem
internen Modem 13,9
Watt. Schaltet man dann das
DSL-Modem ein, werden das nur 0,9
Watt mehr, beim Glasfasermodem
1,6 Watt mehr. Also deshalb
für mich ganz klar, wenn möglich
einen Router nutzen, der einen eingebauter
Modem hat. Ja, sonst verbraucht man halt
ziemlich viel Extraenergie. Aber jetzt
ist es ja auch endlich soweit. Der erste
Router mit 6 Gigahertz
und eingebautem Modem oder sogar
Modems Plural. Eben die
Fritzbox 5690 Pro und
hab ich ja grad schon gesagt, da stecken ein
Glasfaser und... Wurde AVM jetzt
eigentlich verkauft an irgendwelche China-Chinesen
oder noch nicht?
Da war doch was. Hat da
irgendjemand doch den Überblick
aktuell? Oder waren das Amis?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass die verkauft werden.
Sollten,
wollte, wollten sich, die wollten
sich verkaufen. Lass mich
grad mal kurz gucken. Ich bin ja gestern zum ersten Mal
Fahrrad gefahren. Was hab ich denn für
normalized Wattwerte
gehabt gestern?
154, na das ist nicht so
nix, womit man angeben kann.
Ein DSL Modem
drin. Leider kein Kabelmodem, was
ich hier in meinem Haushalt bräuchte, aber
ja gut, meine Neugier war natürlich höher,
sodass ich das Ding natürlich trotzdem getestet
hab. Also erstmal ganz kurz, was
das Ding überhaupt kann. Die
5690 Pro ist eine
von drei bei... Was ist an der
jetzt Pro?
7 kompatiblen Fritzboxen von AVM,
aber die einzige, die das 6 GHz
Band unterstützt. Und es ist auch
die erste... Moment, gibt es nicht
7000er Fritzboxen schon?
Warum ist die
5000er Fritzbox moderner
als die 7000...
Ah, da blickt auch keiner mehr durch.
...mit zwei Modems. Offenbar
ist das für den Umstieg gedacht. Also für Leute,
die jetzt noch DSL nutzen und bald auf
Glasfaser aufrüsten wollen.
Ja, das würde ich gerne, wenn die bei mir mal ausbauen.
Also ich habe aktuell Kabel von
Vodafone,
aber ich hätte gerne einen
Glasfaseranschluss. Und bei mir macht
die Telekom seit neuestem super viel
Werbung für High Speed Internet.
Da ist ein QR-Code drauf. Und wenn man den QR-Code
scannt, kommt man dann raus bei
VDSL Vectoring
Keck Wait in 2024.
Fünf Ethernet-Ports hat die
6590 Pro. Davon kann aber nur auch...
...einer 2,5 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Die anderen sind auf 1 Gigabit
beschränkt. Das ist heutzutage eigentlich
schon ein bisschen wenig, wenn man bedenkt, dass
2,5 Gigabit nur 312...
Das ist heutzutage 2,5 Gigabit
pro Sekunde. Das ist... Da würde ich
tatsächlich erwarten, dass alle Ports mittlerweile
2,5 Gig sind. Zumal das bestimmt
die billigste Fritzbox ist. Die anderen
sind auf 1 Gigabit beschränkt. Das ist
heutzutage eigentlich schon ein bisschen wenig,
wenn man bedenkt, dass 2,5 Gigabit
nur 312 Megabyte pro Sekunde
bedeutet. Also wenn man SSD-Nasen
hat und da richtig viel Daten rumschieben will...
Nice!
Endlich, ja!
Also wenn man
SSD-Nasen hat und
da richtig viel Daten rumschieben will...
Naja, okay, ich schweife ab. Auf jeden Fall
unterstützt die 5690 Pro
neben dem Schnurrlossfunk
DECT ULE auch noch
die zusätzliche Smartphone-Technik
Zigbee im 2,4 Gigahertz.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Wenn das als
weiterer
Zigbee quasi... Wie heißt das?
Router heißt
das bei Zigbee, glaube ich.
Also die, die quasi
das P2P-Netzwerk weiter
erweitern.
Fungiert ist das sehr nice.
Herzband, ja.
Das ist ja ganz nice. Achso, wenn euch
interessiert, was da genau drin ist in der 5690 Pro,
da blenden wir euch jetzt hier mal ein,
was wir da rausgefunden haben.
Das ist auch viel mehr, als in den Datenblättern steht
und auf der AVM-Website. Wir haben das Ding nämlich
aufgeschraubt und da mal genau
geguckt. So, aber es soll ja vor allem
darum gehen, ob mir das Teil jetzt
zu Hause so einen richtigen WLAN-Turbo bringt.
Und da bin ich dann fast
ein bisschen mit meinen CT-Kollegen aneinandergeraten,
weil die erfahrungsgemäß
immer die Hände zusammenschlagen, wenn man
irgendwelche Messungen macht, bei denen man
die äußeren Umstände nicht kontrollieren kann.
Ist ja auch verständlich. Wenn meine Nachbarn
irgendwie 24-7 Mikrowellen-Popcorn
massenprodu... Die hat garantiert
keinen Matrix-Endpoint.
Im Leben nicht.
Oder 10 Leute aus der Nachbarschaft... Aber man
kann bestimmt mit Trick 17
einen Prometheus-Metrik-Endpoint
irgendwie machen für eine Fritzbox, oder?
Also, nicht auf der Fritzbox
selbst, sondern irgendwas,
was über Trick 17
die Fritzbox-Daten ab... von der Fritzbox
Daten abfragt oder scraped
und dann als Prometheus-kompatible
Metriken raushaut.
Da gibt's bestimmt
irgendwas. Aber es wäre natürlich
cool, wenn die Fritzbox sowas von Haus aus hätte, aber
das werden wir
nicht sehen. Ist ja auch in gewisser Weise
verständlich, weil...
Wer außer uns hier
interessiert sich für sowas?
... irgendwie alle gleichzeitig das Netz
vollballern, ja, dann messe ich
komische Dinge, ist klar. Deshalb wird
bei CT grundsätzlich im
Funksmog-freien Keller gemessen, unter
sehr kontrollierten Bedingungen. Aber
hier geht's ja gerade um Funksmog.
Also 6 GHz ist ja aus exakt
diesem Grund freigegeben worden, um halt
mit zusätzlichen Frequenzen ein Gegenmittel
zu den gerade in Innenstädten
mit WLAN-Smog vollgemüllten
Netzen zu haben. Deshalb hier jetzt
der 3003-Kompromiss. Ich zeige
euch zuerst die sauberen Messergebnisse
von meinem Kollegen Ernst Ahlers
und dann die Ergebnisse von
mir aus der, naja, wilden
Echtwelt in Hannover City.
Erstmal die sauberen Messungen.
Also im CT-Messkeller,
da zeigten sich ganz klar Vorteile
bei 6 GHz.
Da wurden nämlich unter Optimalbedingungen,
also direkt neben dem Router... Ja, das sind so
Dinger, die sind mir persönlich fast egal,
weil die maximale
Übertragungsrate im WLAN, das ist jetzt
nichts, das so für mich
Entscheidendes, ja. Geil, kriege ich
theoretisch Maximum
1,8 Gigabyte, äh, ne nicht Gigabyte,
Gigabit drüber.
Oder was auch immer das hier heißen soll.
Megabit. Ja, okay.
1,8 Gigabit. Das ist natürlich
nice, aber
wenn ich so nah dran bin, stecke ich ein Kabel dran.
Ne?
Pro Sekunde
gemessen. Als Client wurde das
Windows Notebook Dell XPS 13
mit WiFi 7 verwendet.
Das hab ich mir dann später auch geholt für die Tests
in meinen Wohnungen. Im 5 GHz
Modus waren es bei
Ernst noch 1406 Mbit.
Ja, und mit 2,4 GHz
dann nur noch 345
Mbit. Alles unter Optimalbedingungen.
In 20 Meter Abstand durch
Steinwände bei uns im CT-Messkeller
ging die Übertragungsrate dann
rapide runter. Ja, genau. Dann waren das maximal auf
allen Spektren nur noch
356 Mbit.
Kurz mal zwischengeschoben. Ja, Rachekloster,
ich dachte mir, dass es sowas gibt.
Viele von euch werden das wissen, aber ich sag das trotzdem noch mal kurz.
Je höher die Frequenz, desto höher
die Geschwindigkeit, aber leider auch desto
geringer die Reichweite. Ja. Das heißt mit
2,4 GHz. Hab ich aber einfach auch schon
gesagt. Am lahmsten, aber kann
die längsten Distanzen oder die meisten
Wände überwinden. Bei 6 GHz
ist das umgekehrt. Also schnell.
Wer am langsamsten ist, kann am längsten. Dell, dafür
reicht es.
So, und jetzt kommen wir mal zu den Messungen
bei mir zu Hause. Das habe ich folgendermaßen
gemacht. Es war in meiner Wohnung nur die Fritzbox
und der jeweilige Client aktiv.
Gemessen habe ich das mit iPerf3
auf einem Windows-Rechner als Server,
der mit 2,5 Gb per Kabel
angebunden war. Also genauso wie bei Ernst
im CT-Rapport. Alle Messungen habe ich
an drei unterschiedlichen Orten gemacht.
Einmal optimal direkt neben dem Router,
einmal in meinem Arbeitszimmer durch
zwei Innenwände und einmal auf dem Balkon
durch eine Innenwand
und eine Außenwand.
Als Client habe ich drei unterschiedliche Geräte
verwendet. Einmal das Windows Notebook
Dell XPS 13, also wie Ernst,
und zusätzlich das Smartphone
Google Pixel 8 Pro mit
WiFi 7 und außerdem das
iPhone 15 Pro, das
nur WiFi 6 kann, aber mindestens
6 GHz. Ja, und wisst ihr was?
Bei mir zu Hause habe ich Ernst-Messungen
sogar einmal toppen können.
Da sind mir tatsächlich einmal glatte
2000 Mbit gelungen mit dem
XPS 3.
Ich bin direkt am Router. Das ist tatsächlich
ungefähr das Doppelte, was ich an
gleicher Stelle mit gleichem Client mit
meinem alten WiFi 6 Router erreicht
habe. Aber halt nichts, was wirklich
notwendig ist, ne? Also Entfernung
und gute Abdeckung in der Wohnung ist für
WLAN dann deutlich wichtiger als direkt
neben dem Router. Das ist eine Fritzbox
6690, da waren es nur
950 Mbit. Also ganz
klar, WiFi 7 gepaart mit
6 GHz bringt unter optimalen
Bedingungen auf allen drei Clients
mindestens 400 Mbit mehr im
Vergleich zum WiFi 6 Router
mit 5 GHz. Ich merke gerade,
dass das hier jetzt etwas krass wird mit den
Zahlen, mit denen ich hier so rumwerfe.
Also, wenn euch das gerade zu viel Input ist,
einfach mal Pause drücken. Die Tabelle
erklärt sich eigentlich von selbst.
So, also.
Okay, Balkon. Ja,
hier sind wir dann schon eher.
Aber bringt auch.
Bringt auch ordentlich was.
Das hier finde ich ist eigentlich
schon am besten.
Guck mal, der Unterschied von WiFi 6.
Moment, Moment. Ist das überhaupt?
Ach, Moment. Wait a minute.
6 GHz?
Moment, jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Die ist langsamer?
Ja gut, weil schlechter durch Wände
geht wahrscheinlich, ja?
Gehe ich auf der Tonspur jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter
über die Tabelle rüber.
Kurios ist zum Beispiel die Performance des
Pixel 8 Pro. Das schafft im absolut
besten Fall nur 1210
Mbit. Das iPhone 15 Pro,
was ja gar kein WiFi 7 beherrscht, erreicht
auf 6 GHz 1510
Mbit. Also 300 Mbit
mehr. Hä? Ja, okay, woran das
liegt, das ist natürlich aus dem Stehgreif schwierig
zu sagen. Aber es könnte damit zu tun haben,
dass Pixel 8 Pro keine 320
MHz Signalbreite beherrscht, was
bei WiFi 7 nämlich optional
ist. Aber so richtig interessant wird
es bei nicht optional... Warum ist eigentlich bei neuen
Standards der Trend mittlerweile Sachen
optional zu machen? Sei es HDMI
oder USB oder sonst wie.
Wenn was draufsteht, kannst du dich mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr darauf verlassen, dass das auch drin ist.
Also durch Wände
in meinem Arbeitszimmer oder auf dem Balkon.
Da ist nämlich der beste Wert, den ich gemessen habe,
360 Mbit. Und
den erreicht kurioserweise der
einzige WiFi 6 Client, also
das nicht WiFi 7 kompatible
iPhone mit der Fritzbox
65 Pro. Mit der älteren
WiFi 6 Fritzbox 6690
sind es aber auch 352
Mbit. Ja und den einzigen anderen
Messwert über 300 Mbit auf dem Balkon
oder Arbeitszimmer schafft das
XPS 13 Notebook und zwar auch mit der
WiFi 6 Fritzbox 6690.
Also im Prinzip vollkommen
egal. Sagt uns das.
Erstmal ganz klar, WiFi 7 und
6 GHz bringen auf jeden Fall deutlich
mehr Geschwindigkeit als WiFi 6 bzw.
5 GHz, aber halt nur unter
Optimalbedingungen. Also im gleichen Raum
mit dem Router. Sobald das durch
Wände geht, ja da ist das alles
nicht mehr so deutlich. Wir sehen hier bei meinen
Messungen, dass die alte WiFi 6 Fritzbox
6690 in einigen Fällen
tatsächlich eine schnellere Übertragung schafft
als die neue 5690.
Also das ist natürlich jetzt eine Momentaufnahme
also Mitte August 2024
die Firmware der
neuen Box ist ja brandneu
und die 6690 ist in Sachen Software
natürlich ausgereift und auch
die WiFi 7 Hard und
Software der Clients ist noch frisch.
Da kann sich also noch einiges tun.
So gibt es zum Beispiel noch keine Clients mit der
sogenannten MLMR Funktion
mit der Clients gleichzeitig in
mehreren Bändern senden können. Was jetzt schon
geht ist EMLSR
allerdings hier auch nur zu zwei Dritteln
Alter die Abkürzung immer.
Clients können gleichzeitig in mehreren
Funkbändern verbunden sein und können dann Daten
dynamisch. Wie hieß das nicht früher
IO
oder MIMO oder so?
Oder ist das wieder
was anderes?
... über den besten Link verschicken.
Das senkt dann die Latenz und erhöht vor allem
die Stabilität. Schade ist natürlich nur,
dass die 5690 Pro das ganze
nur mit 5 und 6 GHz unterstützt
nicht auf 2,4 GHz.
Mein Fazit, also
eine vielleicht etwas naive Vorstellung,
dass mit 6 GHz
alles mit Gigabit-Geschwindigkeiten
fluppt, das ist in der Realität
nicht so. Aber ganz klar, unter
optimalen Bedingungen, also im gleichen Raum,
schafft die 5690 Pro
mit 3,7 GHz mit
allen 3 getesteten Clients
über 1 Gigabit und bis zu
2 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Und das ist für WLAN-Verhältnisse natürlich
richtig gut. Ja, aber sobald Wände
dazwischen sind, ja dann wird es dann deutlich
lahmer, aber halt immer noch meistens
deutlich dreistellig. Und für einen
4K-Videostream empfiehlt zum Beispiel
Netflix lediglich 15 Mbit pro Sekunde.
Das reicht also, alles locker.
Dennoch, für mich persönlich ist jetzt klar,
dass ich mit meinem WiFi 6
Router absolut gut bedient bin und noch
nicht auf WiFi 7 und 6 GHz.
Also, mein gesamtes Haus
hat nur 2,4
und 5 GHz WLAN aktuell
und ich muss sagen, seitdem ich die neuen
Access Points seit ein paar Jahren habe, diese
Ruckus Access Points,
ich kann mich nicht beschweren.
Ich habe Empfang im Keller,
ich habe Empfang im Erdgeschoss, ich habe
Empfang im ersten Stock, ich habe Empfang
unter dem Dach, ich habe Empfang
auf dem Balkon, äh, nicht auf dem Balkon, auf der
Terrasse, im Hof,
sogar noch am Anfang vom
Garten und
auf der Straße draußen
mit 2 Access
Points.
Ein Access Point hier
gegenüber vom Arbeitszimmer im Wohnzimmer
an der Decke und
ein Access Point unten
an der Wand im Keller.
... als umsteigen muss. Aber das liegt halt auch daran,
dass bei mir hier das
5 GHz Band noch ziemlich frei
ist. Wenn das bei euch nicht so ist, dann kann
6 GHz euch natürlich helfen.
Was mir in Zukunft allerdings vermutlich
mehr bringen würde, ein Router mit einer
10 Gigabit Ethernet Anbindung,
sodass ich meinen SSD Home Server
bzw. dessen NAS Funktion,
dazu haben wir ja schon mehrere Videos gemacht, voll
ausnutzen kann. Router mit 10 Gigabit
Ethernet Anbindung und
6 GHz gibt es inzwischen ab 470 Euro.
Hier zum Beispiel den TP-Link
Archer BE-
Das Ding sieht ja mal richtig
kacke aus. Das sieht aus wie ein USV.
Es sieht eher aus wie ein
USV anstatt so einen Router, oder?
Ja, oder wie eine
Xbox von Wish.
Oder wenn es noch etwas martialischer
aussehen soll, kann man auch diese
Roboterspinne hier von Asus nehmen.
Die kostet rund 700 Euro.
Bitte daran denken, da sind keine Modems
drin. Also,
ohne Scheiß, wenn ich 700
Euro für ein Nexus Point ausgebe,
da kaufe ich mir einen gebrauchten
bei Ebay von den Premium
Anbietern.
Dann kaufe ich mir wirklich wieder so,
da mache ich das gleiche, was ich das letzte Mal gemacht habe,
da würde ich mir jetzt wieder
ein R750 kaufen.
Der hat zwar keinen 6 GHz,
aber
ziemlich gutes 811
Punkt
802.11ax
Ist das richtig?
Ist das WLAN? 802.11ax
also quasi das
vor WiFi 6
oder nee, WiFi 6, AX ist WiFi 6,
oder?
Das WiFi 6
reicht vollkommen aus
und da hat man wenigstens ordentliche
Hardware und super
Einstellungsmöglichkeiten in der Firma.
Also extra. Ja, habt ihr schon
10 Gigabit LAN oder
seid ihr streng WLAN-Omi? Ja, habe ich.
Wie viel Geschwindigkeit braucht ihr?
Ist das für euch alles eh übertrieben?
Warum er 10 Gigabit an der Fritzbox braucht?
Wahrscheinlich, weil er ein NAS hat
mit 10 Gigabit.
Macht ja durchaus Sinn,
wenn der beispielsweise
mehrere Geräte benutzt im WLAN
und da
gleichzeitig Sachen vom NAS
hin übertragen. Ich meine, das ist natürlich
Spielerei. Im Endeffekt passiert
wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel langsamer sein,
aber wenn du mehrere Geräte hast,
kannst du dir
bestimmt Anwendungsfälle
konstruieren. Es wäre aber
auf jeden Fall mal davon abgesehen sinnig,
wenn du ein 10 Gigabit NAS hast,
dass die Fritzbox auch ein 10 Gigabit Port bietet.
Gerade bei den Preisen
finde ich das mittlerweile durchaus
gerechtfertigt, dass man da mal ein 10 Gigabit
Port kriegt.
Bevorzugt tatsächlich ein 10 Gigabit Kupferport,
weil die meisten Leute damit noch eher klarkommen.
Es könnte aber auch natürlich ein 10 Gigabit
SFP Plus Port sein.
Da würde man sich ein Direct Attached Kabel
reinstecken und
gut ist.
Ich meine,
Direct Attached ist auch ein Kupferkabel.
Bevorzugt halt mit einem AR45
Stecker, weil da die meisten Leute noch am besten mit
klarkommen. AR45
Stecker kennen die Leute.
Ja, nein, nein.
SFP Plus Connector
Direct, ne, Connect, Direct,
Direct Connect, wie heißt das Ding nochmal?
Direct Connect, oder? Sind auch Kupferkabel.
Gehen aber, glaube ich, maximal nur
5 Meter oder so.
Nicht so weit wie
AR45
Kupferkabel.
Ja.
Direct Attached, nicht
Direct Connected.
Direct Attached, das meine ich, ja.
Genau, ein Duck.
Das meine ich, ja.
Das habe ich gemeint.
Na, was ist es?
Heute, wo sich die meisten Leute
kennenlernen,
ist es irgendwelche Apps
online, ja klar, ne. Das wundert mich nicht.
Ja, online zählen wahrscheinlich
eben die Dating Apps dazu.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Leute gehen auch mit der Zeit.
Warum sich immer noch kein besserer Stecker für Netzwerk
etabliert hat?
Der AR45 Stecker ist doch gut.
Und der Vorteil von einem
AR45 Stecker ist einfach, jedes
Gerät weiß
für Netzwerk brauchen wir einen AR45
Stecker.
Also, es gibt ja auch keine wirklich
anderen, also warum, warum bräuchte
man einen anderen Stecker? AR45 Stecker ist,
ist doch super, super Geschichte.
Die Leute haben teilweise ihr Haus
mit AR45
Steckdosen versehen
und so, das ist jetzt irgendwie zu ändern, also wir müssen ja nicht,
du hast ja nicht mal einen Vorteil
dadurch großartig, den Stecker zu ändern.
Man muss ja nicht einfach nur den Stecker
ändern, einfach um den Stecker zu ändern.
Hast du auch mal
vor ein Video zu deiner Fitnessreise,
Fitnessreise? Du meinst,
okay, du meinst jetzt nicht,
ob ich auf Mallorca
war zum Fahrradfahren oder so,
du meinst so
der Weg quasi von Anfang
zu jetzt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das die Leute großartig interessiert.
Zur Not
kann man AR45 Stecker
auch relativ einfach reparieren,
beziehungsweise neue Stecker
draufmachen.
Weil die Kabel dafür gemacht sind, dass du
easy neue Stecker draufkriegst.
Bei einem USB Kabel sieht das ein bisschen anders aus.
Mach da mal einen neuen USB Stecker dran.
Als Noob.
Ein AR45 Stecker kriegt auch
einer, der sich ein Tutorial angeguckt hat, drauf.
Mit dem passenden
Set.
Mittlerweile hast du ja schon so Einfädel-Hilfen.
Und es gibt
ja sogar auch selbst
krimpende
Stecker. Die musst du einfach
nur zusammenklappen. Da brauchst
du noch nicht mal eine Zange dafür.
Und ganz ehrlich,
ein abgebrochener
Pin ist nicht verkehrt,
weil je nachdem,
ob du jemand bist, der öfters über das Kabel
stolpert oder nicht, reißt
dir so nix aus dem Rechner raus, wenn du mal
übers Kabel fällst.
Ja, SFP-Module ist nice, aber das überfordert
die normalen Leute daheim.
Zumal die Stecker schon ganz komisch aussehen.
Die sind so lang.
Du hast bei
IOT11 einfach zu wenig Kabel
für schnelles Ethernet.
Du brauchst ja 8
Adern oder so. Was ist denn
8, oder? Sind das 8
Kabel?
8 Adern?
In so einem aktuellen Kabel?
8, ja, ne?
Also ich glaube,
für 10 Gig brauchst du 8.
Ich glaube sogar für Gigabit
brauchst du schon 8.
Wenn du weniger hast, dann geht nur 100.
Genau, ja.
Du kannst mit 6 Kabeln
kannst du glaube ich 100 Mbit und PoE machen.
PoE 2 Stück
und 4
zum Übertragen.
Also mit 6 Adern kommt man irgendwie
für 100 Mbit hin.
So habe ich übrigens den Access Point im Keller
angeschlossen. Da geht über PoE
und ich habe nicht genug
Adern frei gehabt.
Der synkt glaube ich nur mit 100 Mbit.
Aber PoE.
Da habe ich selbst einen Stecker drauf gemacht
und ein
Custom Kabel
oder sind es auch 8?
Ach, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe eigentlich schon rebooted heute.
Gucken wir mal, was die Package-Updates
machen. Wir haben jetzt immerhin schon 2 Stunden keine
Package-Updates gemacht.
Aber was ist das gewesen?
Guck mal, ich habe hier ein Passwort geechoet.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Bestimmt nichts wichtiges, oder?
Reboot.
Ja, Leute.
Ich habe Hunger.
Ich glaube es ist PepoFatTime.
PoE gibt es mehrere Standards.
Ich glaube PoE hat
12V, 24V
und 48V.
Gibt es mehrere.
Das heißt, du kannst über ein Netzwerkkabel
schicken, was du willst.
Solange das Endgerät damit klarkommt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel ein altes
Netzwerkkabel dazu missbraucht
für die
Tür-Gegen-Sprechanlage
Strom
durch die Wand zu führen.
Ne, Tabs werden nicht
weniger.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, was es heute gibt, Leute.
Lachs mit Nudeln gab es letzte
Woche.
Was füttert der Pepo heute?
Ne, der trinkt Energydrinks.
Bolognese, korrekt.
Nudeln mit Tomatensauce gibt es heute.
Das sind wenige Tabs.
Das ist auch der falsche Browser.
Du meinst den hier, ne?
Leute, wir hören uns.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
See you.